Can you say something again?
Yammer right here?
Uh,
I'll say whatever you been out
of that a nice going to do today.
I'm picking up the audio
again and there's no echo.
So let me get back to the live.
I can't even see.
I really need two computer monitors.
I mean I have computer monitors,
I just don't,
I have my desk setup since I,
I've moved
so I can always have youtube
live on and the other one.
Oh boy.
Yeah.
Okay.
So,
uh,
let's see if they,
it was this guy swamping mcgee.
Okay.
Well any heroes?
Oh my God.
Maybe
I could hear him right now.
Not on it right now.
Of course you checked me.
Just go back to them.
Okay.
So I'm skipping the daughter that's check.
Devote works on her own.
Okay.
Yeah,
she said that she can hear me,
but not.
You asked,
you said though?
Oh man,
that's not good because I'm
picking up your audio right now.
Steve Nichols.
Sorry,
I'm picking up your audio
right now through obs.
So it should be routing.
Okay.
I've turned my volume up quite a bit.
Uh,
I don't want to crank
it to and rapes my ears,
but.
Alright.
So,
so it looks like we're good,
I think.
Oh really?
Uh,
I can hear us both.
Yeah,
that's bad.
That's bad.
No Echo on no echo on either one.
It must've been some priorities,
driver issue that right things
in the right order or something
or something.
Ice.
It makes me happy
because I knew nothing
to do at that point.
Nothing I could do.
Okay.
Alright.
So
you were alright.
So back to the Sargon
yeah.
Yeah.
So uh,
you had asked me if I had a
watched the video and I finished it
today a few hours ago and uh,
you know,
one of the things that,
that I had mentioned to you
in the beginning because
I hadn't watched the rest
of the video,
was how like,
uh,
that group,
Chapo Trap House basically a
seemed to be siting with A.
I'm forgetting the director's name again.
I can't remember his name.
What was it?
Over Verhoeven?
Yeah,
I'll remember that now.
Relevant for Hoven a diaper.
I rewatched the that day too,
just
to keep up with it.
But yeah,
if go,
yeah.
And so verhoeven was,
uh,
was basically creating what he thought
was a movie based off have based off of
but a movie,
um,
or a story that he believed
was a fascistic and uh,
you know,
Sargon pointed out that,
well,
you know,
it's a voluntary society.
Everybody who joins up,
you know,
does so willingly,
nobody's conscripted and
yeah,
it's almost,
it's almost like verhoeven
didn't even read the book,
which is true.
You didn't actually read it.
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't really.
It was like,
oh,
it's over fighting with the
source material constantly.
Like,
that made no sense because you
didn't hit second year already.
You hardly use the source material.
It was like,
it was like that old Batman show.
It's not really bad,
man.
It was like,
almost like a sharp.
Yeah.
And compared to good.
And they considered it fascistic,
you know,
they considered it to be
a work of fascism and uh,
it doesn't.
No,
it doesn't make sense to me.
The only way I could,
I could,
you know,
see it or see them as interpreting
it as fast as well as being this,
uh,
like them using the Arachnids as them
not taking a literal approach to the
story,
but you know,
rather than being arachnids maybe it
could be humans and because I never read
the book,
I don't know if the directors are still
the same insect creatures where they
are.
Oh,
there's a couple of races actually
there's the terrans with other humans and
then there's the skinnies which the
way they describe and is very strange.
So you have to kind of use your
imagination but just imagine like a really
skinny alien guy.
And then there's directors and in the
beginning of the rapids are sort of allied
with the skinnies and then over time
the human start like rating the skinnies
and basically thought not killing a lot
of them but just kinda like fucking shit
up.
And in doing so they get the skinny to
change sides to give them intelligence
and how to help the feed the,
it's because the humans aren't doing
very well in the book against them.
So,
uh,
they kind of have to turn the skinnies
first and it opens up with a sore toe
against the skinnies and
it's quite descriptive.
I mean,
it is science fiction,
so it was way different than the movie,
like the movie.
Um,
the way their hoven shows it,
it was clearly you didn't read the book.
He clearly,
he must have been fighting with
the writer because the writer,
I read the book,
but they must've just been a constant
battle to get things properly in there.
There are some things,
we're obviously,
they had to squish it all together,
you know,
because the way they filled
with adapt from movies or um,
sort of films with that from books.
But a lot of the stuff
didn't make a lot of sense.
Yeah.
Well,
I think that if verhoeven
had actually read the book,
he would have had more of an argument
of it being a metaphor for fascism in
that,
and I,
I may be completely wrong,
but you know,
if,
if humans were,
were committing the
violence against humans,
I mean,
if it wasn't the same,
the same to the same capacity where
the Arachnids we're just mindless
destroyers,
then you know,
you could,
you could say,
well,
you know,
the human,
the Terran,
we're just protecting themselves.
But you know,
if they weren't,
if they weren't protecting themselves.
But see,
that's the thing is that I,
I don't,
I haven't read the book.
I mean with the skinnies not violent
and did the terran initiate violence
against the skin and all of this is
irrelevant because verhoeven did read the
book.
But I mean now I'm trying
to make a case for fascism.
You know,
skinnies weren't even really
involved like even in the book,
but we just talked about.
And uh,
they were,
they had kind of switched
sides to the humans.
Yeah.
Detail to really,
I guess maybe make part of the movie.
So maybe that's why they didn't include
them because I was confused at first I
was reading the book and I'm like,
where's the Arachnids?
They're like fighting news.
We're thinking still skinnies.
And then,
uh,
in the movie
sample is another part where there's
like the Mormon extreme mormon columnists
or whatever,
but they're not in the book at all.
And even after I finished
the book I was like,
Hey,
wait a minute.
Wasn't there like Mormon
columnists or something?
Did I like miss those pages?
But no,
they're just not in the book at all.
I went online just to make sure it
wasn't fucked up because I read,
I read the book pretty quickly
over a period of a couple of days.
So,
um,
yeah,
I was just worried.
I maybe like,
must have like blanked out,
but I know there is no mormons in
the book at all of us just made up.
I guess they have to make
him look bad or something.
I don't know.
Yeah.
But I wonder if the
good
that was going to say I wonder
what verhoeven's outside of,
you know,
being a director,
what his politics are.
You know,
what he,
what he believes,
you know,
I mean,
I guess we kind of.
All right,
well my guess is that he's kind of not,
like not a far left.
It's like a default socialist or be
full Democrat sort of thing through to
translate to American politics.
Yeah,
definitely a social democrat,
like not nothing in the movie.
Even the movie like it's funny,
I think if he thought it wasn't a,
I think if you had not
thought it was a fascist,
like based system,
I think he probably wouldn't have made
the movie because then he wouldn't have
been able to market.
I think he probably would have like
the movie wouldn't have gotten made,
so maybe it's a good thing that he kind
of fucked it up because that way at
least the film was presented.
Yeah,
that's probably the,
uh,
the recipe to his success.
Just a making a mockery of something.
Just Straw manning a
straw man or something,
you know,
it doesn't exist.
Yeah,
exactly.
Uh,
it's really easy.
I don't have a lot of
people talk about like,
um,
there's like rising outright
and fascism or whatever.
Uh,
but it's really the easiest,
it's one of the easiest ideologies to
make fun of because they're both rooted in
a collective level of [inaudible]
and he galleon like collectivism,
which I was just listening.
I was listening to your,
uh,
the,
the link you sent me a camera.
That was the.
Oh yeah,
it was the stability and excellent Quinn's
Slobodin I think that was listening
to him.
And then I listened to a,
uh,
also today,
Steven Hicks explaining postmodernism.
Have you read or listened
to that a while ago?
I think when,
when I first started
listening to Peterson,
I listened a little bit too,
Steven Hicks and I can't remember much
of what I heard and I can't recall the,
uh,
the Peterson Steven Hicks conversation.
Oh,
I,
I listened,
I listened to Steven Hicks
has audio book explaining,
explaining postmodernism.
He has a couple of interviews.
I guess you'd be,
I'd probably see on
the same ones you have,
but I've listened to the audiobook and
it goes into like the detail from the
medieval ages basically.
Okay,
cool.
Can you give me the gist of it?
Yeah,
well he runs through like how
postmodernism came to be then it Kinda,
it's,
it's a six hour audio books,
so it's Kinda hard to make
it smaller to understand,
but I recommend listening to that.
But essentially,
um,
you go from Emmanuel Kant,
so you have the,
uh,
the enlightenment movement,
which is this idea that things are real
and you can sense things and you'd get
like empiricists and uh,
a rationalist and these different groups
that kind of compete with each other,
but they believe the world's real right.
And it works.
It works really well for science,
but it doesn't work so well with like the,
uh,
spiritual humanity side of things.
And that's,
that was exposed by Emmanuel Kant.
He was part of the counter enlightenment.
And over time you find,
can't,
uh,
see,
he says,
well,
science is fine,
that it's explaining about these things,
but you can't explain the
other half of humanity,
the humanities and like a religion,
for example.
Uh,
with the same techniques
because they don't match match.
Like for example,
you know how you,
if you drink a,
uh,
an orange tastes sweet,
right?
When do you eat an orange but not
after you drink like a sugary drink?
Yeah.
So it,
what he's saying is like,
well,
how do you know whether the orange is
sweet or what was the true nature of it?
Because it's sweet when
you get it on its own,
but if you needed after
eating the chocolate cake,
it tastes sour.
So he goes into those sorts of things
and that's just the subjectivity of,
uh,
your sense or the
subjectivity of empiricism,
I guess since data,
right.
That's parasitism,
right?
Um,
so you're saying you can't trust it.
Yeah.
So from,
um,
Kantz a,
that's where the,
that's where the German school kind of
booked this anchor in with cans and uh,
like the first one to the mirror
and you say journalists before,
oh,
this is way before that I'm
talking to like Prussia and stuff.
Uh,
so can't,
became a sort of the German continental
sort of system of philosophy versus like
the British and French more,
uh,
a more opportune,
sort of a philosophy like
unlocking philosophy is like
basically what the United
States was founded on Rehab
your rights and all that stuff.
Um,
but in,
in Germany is different.
Like the way their philosophy came about
was a lot another thing sargon goes
into in another video
where he talks about how,
because of the German question,
you know,
as a joke,
um,
but uh,
he goes into how like the Germans are
very imperialist and they seem to try to
reform an empire of the good they call it.
And this goes back to Russia would like
Frederick the great and he formed the,
you started like public schools for
boys and you've tried to make his army
professional rather than
being peasants and stuff.
And it developed this sort
of like Germans superiority.
And uh,
oh,
the German doesn't need to be educated.
They're fine being a dom and pour on the
farm and that's that they're superior
people and all this other stuff.
And that,
that developed slowly with it eventually
that Kinda came up in some parts as
Nazi-ism in some parts as
Marxism in competition,
like as,
as,
as a collective ideology.
And that's where you see all the
collective ivl she's came from,
they came from like a,
he galleon then marks and then do a
genteel gentilly on the fascist side of
things.
They came out to be a collectivist.
And if you look at the British
and the American side of politics,
you get a very individualist policies,
even though I would say Britain's less
individuals than the United States,
it still is a,
it's way more
individualistic than Germans.
Then you've got the French,
which are kind of like a mix.
So they were very individualistic.
Then the lock Ian's last up to the
resilience during the French revolution.
And then,
uh,
Napoleon eventually
filled that power vacuum,
right?
So you can see the,
you can see the French switch
from individualism to imperialism,
which is a,
during the revolution
from say the ropes peer,
a peer that was like walking.
So then rose Pierre took over,
he came,
he sort of brought the roof.
Sophia and ideas in and then
after that came the polio,
eventually after rubs,
pier was destroyed or had his head
chopped off and their policies all changed
and then you get a French empire
and they competed with the Russians.
Then eventually he falls because,
uh,
all of your allies against them
essentially in the pulling on a course.
Yeah.
I'm getting it
history lesson in philosophy
and philosophy and how
it impacts almost running
out of breath,
but yeah.
Yeah.
So basically it's just a in a,
you can't really see.
You can always start from a
particular place because it,
it evolved over time.
All this stuff.
So it's hard to pinpoint when
likes a postmodern ideas happen.
But you could say they happened with Kant.
He might've been like the first prototype
postmodernist before modernism even
existed.
Like he was the seed of it.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
A university I went to a,
she didn't graduate from,
but then I went to,
was it a Catholic?
A salient.
You'd have a private university and uh,
and was,
uh,
there were quite a few extra lectures,
extra,
um,
things that you could attend a
highlighting the words of con.
Um,
I just remember seeing
through the brochures a thing,
extra things that you could attend and
a lot of them had to do with a manual.
Yeah.
Ideas.
His philosophy.
What was,
when I was in elementary school,
I first came across Canada because we
had to do a project on a philosopher in
our philosophy class.
I just chose con.
I don't know what the fuck I was doing.
I was like grade eight.
So I just chose count because uh,
no one else chose them and whatever
that I learned a little bit about.
Um,
then,
uh,
I didn't really care about them until
recently where I started listening to the
Steven Hicks and he said,
the way he breaks it down
in this book is like,
I'm sort of like the grandfather of the,
uh,
the German School of
philosophy and the from him,
you get like the Eagle who then
he gets split off into UC eagles.
A collectivist,
like people believe like a,
the states,
it,
he,
he believed in the state
almost as strongly as fascist
to basically astronomers
fascist do and Marx took those
ideas and adapted them to be more,
uh,
a brew Sonia and I guess you could say,
and you can also see over time how the
leftists have abandoned marks to some
degree and started to adopt more resilient
ideas of like the noble savage and
stuff like we should go back to the cave
days because back then man was so happy
and wasn't dying of diseases.
And you're being murdered
at super high res.
Right?
So does that like split classes to be
extreme or you kind of do away with
glasses and just one class?
The elite versus the peasants?
Who a re Rousseau,
Rousseau.
I don't think we're.
So we're so wanting to
get rid of everything.
He,
he wanted to go back to
like a tribal society.
Oh.
Which is,
I mean,
you even know if he,
he would.
He postulated whether or
not that was realistic,
but that's what he said would be the
ideal state because we couldn't go back to
our animal nature,
which is sort of like the Adam
and Eve story with the fruit.
No
eating from the tree of
knowledge and then you know,
you can never go back.
I mean that's just obviously a metaphor,
but yeah,
an interesting one anyways.
Yeah,
I can hear you good.
Okay.
I think the stream just reconnected.
Yeah,
there we go.
Yeah.
I wish I had more of an opinion,
but I don't because you know,
uh,
my retention of a philosophy historically
and how it's impacted nations and say
them over and over again because I
won't get everything the first time,
like not focused on it.
I'm kind of focusing on other banks
but over like we saw like absorbed,
like,
you know,
that all 40 years of my head and
then I can kind of talk about them.
But like the,
you know that Jordan Peterson,
I'm with that lecture series
of maps of meaning 2017.
Yeah.
I think I've listened to
that like four or five times
the first time listen to that,
but first time I listened
to it blew my fucking mind.
Like I couldn't,
it,
it basically,
to me it rationalized religious belief,
like it made it,
it made it make sense,
like in an evolutionary way,
you know,
that's,
that's still kind of blows my mind.
I'm still around.
I'm still working my way through his book,
but I keep getting sidetracked on
other things like starship troopers for
example.
But,
but,
but uh,
but yeah,
the first starship troopers,
a lot of people have this issue with the,
uh,
the voting thing,
right?
Yeah.
What,
what,
what exactly,
because you have to,
uh,
you have to commit to service.
Yeah.
You have to do through
your service a minimum.
Um,
and you have to,
I guess,
earn your right to vote by becoming
conscious of you're a collective
responsibility or social responsibility.
Um,
and civilians don't
have to deal with that.
And it makes a lot of sense.
I meant today there's a
lot of people that have no,
no clue what they're doing,
which is fine.
I guess with our system,
but it turns into more of a
popularity contest then if you,
if you're voting someone
else's money into your pocket,
that's not.
I mean that's just a
really open for abuse,
right?
Yeah.
And for economic prosperity,
you need to have sort of a guarantee of
property rights and that totally takes
away from that in some,
in some way.
I mean,
luckily our system has been relatively
reasonable and we haven't like quote
unquote eating the rich.
But uh,
you never know with our Kazia Cortez the
70 percent rate that's used proposing,
that's insane.
Like quotes back.
She drove us back to like the
19 forties or whatever they can,
fifties when the rates were that high,
uh,
back then,
like the American economy was the only
one that was still industrialized.
That wasn't like flat into
the ground by the war.
So I mean Germany was one of the main
industrial nations before the war.
Right?
And so it was Britain,
but during the war that it
kind of flattened everything.
So all of us left with Americans.
So they kind of had a monopoly
on industrial production.
So that's the reason why wages were
so high and the tax rates for a,
I'm so high because there was the word,
they're gonna move the money to write,
you know,
nowadays you just move it to some third
world country and build a factory and
then,
you know,
your money is there now.
So it's not even the state.
So yeah,
absolutely good decline of
the American economic empire.
Yeah.
And the age of globalization,
you know,
that everything's,
all the tables have turned and uh,
companies can just move
away or like you said,
industry can just move away.
I mean,
it doesn't have to be
centered in the states.
Um,
yeah.
And you,
yeah,
you can see now like with the
way things are in the states.
So like all technology,
um,
before trump,
I think trump's really turned
some things around but uh,
to some limited degree anyways,
but definitely under Obama it was almost
like the economy in the states was
going under a sort of
a controlled decline,
which I think is quite a bad idea
if you want to win elections,
you know.
Well,
um,
I forgot what I was going to say.
Yeah,
sorry I interrupted you there.
No,
no,
you didn't.
Okay.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Well,
there,
you know,
when you mentioned a Kazia Cortez citing,
probably ftrs,
what was it [inaudible] 91 and
96 or whatever percent tax rate.
Um,
I mean even some of the programs,
social programs that they instituted then,
you know,
basically fell flat on their face and,
I don't
know,
it would be all well and good if,
uh,
those taxes,
if,
you know,
there was transparency with what exactly
money went to and how it contributed to
a productivity in the economy,
but don't necessarily know that,
you know,
there isn't any transparency and maybe,
maybe people would be afraid to,
uh,
to now when I say people,
I mean,
um,
anybody who knows
whether it be economists or engineers
or exactly how things are being
misappropriated or mishandled
or the inefficiencies or the,
uh,
unproductive or unproductive African,
nature of,
of the,
you know,
the federal government intervening.
Um,
yeah,
I always thought it was
kind of interesting.
Uh,
well,
not always.
I had recently started to read one
Ralph Nader's books and you know,
basically he,
you know,
he
put forth the concept of,
of taxing
that which humans like least,
you know,
being,
pollution companies that uh,
basically contribute to,
um,
pollution.
Uh,
and I think pothole or 54
had just put out a video,
um,
about climate change and how carbon
taxes in Australia have actually led to
companies in Australia innovating to
the point where they now are saving.
They've been able to save money,
more money over time than
if they had done nothing.
Um,
and uh,
I should have mentioned
this to you before,
but who knows the,
we'd kind of go in this direction,
but that would be kind
of something interesting.
So,
you know,
I'm,
so not only did they,
are they saving money,
but they also started
recapturing some of their,
uh,
some of their emissions and I don't
know if they were recycling them or,
or what,
but the taxes led to a in innovation,
which makes sense because pressure,
you know,
only under pressure or when someone
believes that something needs to change,
does it change?
And
Oh,
that's,
that's true.
But I mean if I hold a gun to your head
and I say like drive the car faster when
you're driving the car,
are you going to drive the car faster?
Yeah.
But I don't necessarily know that,
that,
that uh,
that analogizes well with a component.
Yeah.
With saying as,
because it's a show of force,
right?
Like you're saying like a,
essentially when the state
mandates that you do something,
it's like a show.
It's like you're forced to do it and
if you don't do it then you're going to
experience violence.
So my knowledge is basically like the
government is saying do this or you're
going to be punished like someone's.
And then suddenly you're like,
well,
I guess I have to find
a way to innovate also,
I'm going to suffer.
Um,
it's like someone holding a gun
to your head and saying like,
you know,
drive the car faster
or something like that.
You might start driving the car faster
if you are worried about getting shot.
Yeah,
it is kind of a joke,
but
yeah,
sure.
Go ahead.
No,
it just,
uh,
we,
we had mentioned before,
you know,
it was something that I
speculated on that maybe a,
and this is kind of a tangent,
but maybe the like the Indians from India
who are now taking up,
uh,
not taking up but
kind of moving into the tech sector,
you know,
people coming straight out of southern
Asia moving into the text tech sector,
um,
you know,
maybe them having
experienced less prosperity,
having come from a poor area,
it really made them,
it was the last bit having a Indians
having come from a poor area or an area of
less prosperity has led to them.
Um,
had lived in motivation,
the motivation of being
coming educated and uh,
figuring things out.
So basically the gun to
their head was survival.
It was nature.
It wasn't,
it was another conscious entity.
It was just nature.
You know,
you can,
you can survive in poverty or maybe die.
Yeah.
Or you can educate yourself and you know,
moved to the states and you know,
to what extent that is like the state,
I'm saying you need to pay up.
Uh,
and then thinking,
well,
how are we going to do it?
And an engineer,
engineers getting together and developing
these methods of recapturing the
mission,
emissions,
recycling them.
And then over time,
you know,
they kind of go,
Ooh,
I'm,
we're saving money now.
Are you able to make more money?
And Yeah.
Oh well that made me think of a,
I might be a result of the WTO,
the World Trade Organization,
like allowing for the markets
to be a little more free.
Like for example,
Microsoft or a tech company is might say,
well,
it's cheaper to develop
this technology in Asia.
So they go,
okay,
well because of the WTO rules are
because of the expanded free markets.
We were going to move there.
And that brought opportunity,
uh,
to the poor Indian people to uh,
you know,
maybe even get educated for free or for
relatively cheap because you're going to
be working for cheap anyways.
And then the best of them say,
well screw this,
I'm going to go to the states,
right?
Because I can make more money there.
So a lot of it is just due to the
opening up markets in terms of like these
developing countries
like China for example,
Vietnam.
Um,
it Kinda reminds me,
I'm just gonna step
back like a stage here,
but if you don't mind,
but if you imagine a.
When the US started outsourcing
production to South Asian countries like
Malaysia and Indonesia
and stuff like clothing,
like clothing.
Oh well a lot of people say like,
Oh man,
it's really bad that we outsourced all
our production to these countries because
these people work in like
slave labor conditions.
Right?
Or sweatshop factories and stuff.
Yeah.
That was the big,
uh,
the,
the reason that people were protesting
in 19 ended three against the WTO,
I believe.
Is that those types of arguments.
Yeah.
And it's true that yeah,
they do suck for a little
bit under those conditions,
but the only reason they're working in
those conditions at all is because they
would rather work in those conditions
and their previous conditions,
which was mostly subsistence farming.
Right?
So if you can begin to scrape a living
by with subsistence farming and your life
is basically like a coin toss,
like it usually renting your
land and stuff like your surf.
But if you can get into the factory,
you make twice as much money and it sucks
because it's like not in the West but
you know,
and you're sweating your balls off
and whatever and you getting your arms
chopped off,
but you know,
you make a little bit more money,
then you can send your kids to school
and gain skills and then slowly over time
you can start demanding more wages
and then eventually a demand.
So many wages that they say,
oh,
we're going to pick a factory up
in this other country over here.
And uh,
but by that time you've already gained
those skills and your infrastructure is
increased because factories need roads,
they need plumbing,
they need electricity,
they need a whole bunch
of different things.
Um,
and those are investments made by
the West that made that happen.
So I'll look,
people will.
There is a criticism to say that
these people suffer and producting are
producing things for the west.
Um,
they also pull themselves out of poverty.
Right?
Yeah.
That's a largely happened,
right.
As the,
through globalization.
The markets have opened
up around the world.
Companies have moved out and have some
would argue at the expense of people in
the United States,
uh,
raised the living standard of
poor people around the world.
Yeah.
Uh,
I'd saw this comment
by Steve Nichols here,
is this China Mobile
execution ban suicide nets.
Yeah.
And I know there's a Canadian
recently that just got,
uh,
arrests or he was arrested a couple
of years ago for drug smuggling,
a 200 kilograms of methamphetamines
or something like that.
And uh,
he was sentenced to 15 years originally,
I think.
I don't know if,
I think I heard that he
appealed the sentence,
but apparently it was the state that
appealed the sentence and he got retried
and they recently sent us to death and uh,
that's.
They think it might be a
result of us are resting.
This woman,
I remember her name.
Oh,
she works for.
Yeah.
The hallway woman like Vancouver is
really close to me and then there's,
I know it's funny because she owns like
a bunch of houses there and like it's
really a,
it's almost like a meme that all the
houses of Vancouver owned by Chinese
nationals.
Yeah.
Because,
uh,
we just slide that.
Anyone buy the houses there,
that's why the market.
So one of the reasons the
market's so crazy in Vancouver.
I'll go into that later.
But um,
so they think that might be revenge
for the hallway arrest of that.
A woman that remember going and she's
like the daughter of the founder of the
company.
She founded the chief financial officer.
Anyways,
that's what she is now,
right?
Yeah,
she's the CFO.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
I,
I don't know,
I heard about that.
Uh,
well I read the article on Drudge,
just pulling things up
through drudge and I'm.
Oh,
well yeah.
And then she and they were putting a
little rice sized spy chips and all Huawei
products and that,
those chips were the,
I guess the interface with the
web and would send the data,
the raw data back to
China for the Internet.
And China was getting
old and security secrets.
That's way kind of like,
I guess you'd call them spaceships and a,
the u s is all concerned about,
we call it the,
you know,
the five eyes.
It's like New Zealand,
Australia,
Canada,
UK,
USA,
a,
it's the anglosphere.
Oh,
we all share spy information.
Then the US has been pressuring everyone
to stop buying qua way a technology.
Yeah.
Just they haven't been.
They've embedded like military
people inside the company.
So
yeah,
pretty fucked up there.
Could be stealing our stream right now.
Well,
probably our
China.
Yeah.
I mean the value systems
are completely different to
what do you know about the soldier?
Those,
uh,
you know,
trying to make some of
these knockoff products.
Yes.
Uh,
in fact I was looking at a saxophone mute.
It's basically a big white egg ish
looking thing that I can put my alto
saxophone in and pull
out and there's a $600,
one called Esx that I think has made in
the states or Europe and then there's a
$300 one now that has made in China
and is hailed as just as good.
Yeah,
it's pretty good.
It's pretty crazy.
It's just one of millions of
knock off things that China makes.
Yeah.
Well they would make these
a retro consoles that uh,
we can put like download every game
ever made for like in 64 [inaudible] and
lower and uh,
and just like,
it's like cheap.
You can get them for like 60 bucks or
something like really cheap on Alibaba,
like 30,
maybe 30 bucks or USA.
But um,
they were filling.
Those are the Rom.
So like that's,
that's like considered a
crime here and Soulja boy,
you know,
the rapper or whatever.
He was trying to market
this soldier console,
which is just like you'd buy the Alibaba
version of the console and just write
soulja boy on it with some sticker
and sell it for like 300 bucks.
And we certainly intend to,
I guess that time and uh,
but that's just an example.
That's what we have to get rid of it.
But there's an example of China's
meddling in our technology,
right?
They just steal it.
I bet you if we,
if we could cut them off for 10 years,
they would fall way behind.
Yeah.
A we'll of course the price,
the price of goods would.
If we didn't have any alternative
manufacturing could skyrocket.
And who knows what type of
pressure they would put on.
I mean,
I don't know how big
of a player Taiwan is,
but
oh,
it would definitely be.
We've definitely
experienced price problems,
but yeah,
like for example,
if I go sam,
Samsung a product,
not South Korea,
but a lot of products that come now
only are only to last like five to 10,
like five to 10 years maximum.
I have,
I have a,
a Kenmore sears brand,
a washing machine,
and it works fine.
It's from 19,
uh,
1989 and I,
I'm thinking of replacing it
because it's kind of ugly looking,
but it does the job and if I get a pay
to replace it then I'm going to get some
thing that's an elastic five years,
you know,
so I'm Kinda,
I'm reluctant to get rid of it.
Yeah,
I,
I've,
uh,
this is,
a bit of a tangent,
but I had just popped in to want to
Owen Benjamin streams and he was saying,
Oh,
you wouldn't replace a,
you would,
I forget what he was talking about
when you said you wouldn't replace,
you know,
appliances from 50 years ago.
And it's like,
well,
you know,
that's,
I think I lost you there.
Well he was saying,
you know,
you wouldn't have place,
you would be dumb to want to
replace appliances from 30,
40,
50 years ago.
And I thought to myself like,
well no,
that's why I think you're just a little
bit ignorant of how things have been
made and how the quality
of things have diminished.
And
uh,
yeah,
I mean that's just objective,
really true.
If you ask any like Hvac technician,
uh,
for appliance technician,
um,
now I wouldn't necessarily when
he mentioned his older cars,
yeah,
I wouldn't want to go with an older car.
Um,
but it depends I guess on the model.
Depends on what you want,
but I mean for efficiency,
uh,
I wouldn't go with an older car,
but efficiency,
you know,
not necessarily electrical
efficiency in older appliances,
but you know,
you're not going to be
replacing it for 20,
30,
Oh,
four years.
Know that the whole electrical efficiency
thing is like kind of like an a is
weird anyways.
Like you know,
space heaters,
they're like 99 percent efficient so
you can't really get much more efficient
than that.
So when they say like an
eco friendly or whatever is,
it usually just means it shittier.
I,
so I found,
um,
I mean not for heaters,
but like for washing machine,
I had this washing machine that was
supposed to be ecofriendly or you got like
some kind of rebate from the
government for it and got 50 bucks off.
I'm afraid to a regular one,
but I just found that
didn't wash the clothes,
you know,
I like,
well,
what's the point?
If I got to wash them twice,
you know,
I'm not really being
that much more efficient,
but
yeah,
that doesn't make sense.
Yeah.
Um,
well,
like there's this.
I got this.
Yeah.
Well it's thinking of the environment.
The thing we were talking about earlier.
Yeah.
Uh,
and uh,
people like want to like reduce
the carbon footprint and stuff.
I think it was happening in Australia.
I think that's where it happened.
Yeah.
Well I've been to like,
I used to be on the side of like,
okay,
climate change is bad.
We've got to fix it like away,
right?
Like we gotta do something about it,
like revolutionary style.
Like I used to be kind of a socialist
that way and I'm not anymore at all,
but you know,
I was young.
Yeah.
But anyways,
um,
I used to think that,
okay,
well the scientists are saying this,
so then we should do
what the scientists say.
But then if you look at their models
that they show for the climate change,
it doesn't reflect what we
see in our current timeline,
but maybe there's a
correlation at some level.
But I have,
I've actually been,
I've lost my confidence in it,
which is kind of crazy,
but I've lost my confidence
in their projections.
Yeah.
Um,
and I,
I,
I talked to,
I've talked to some people about it,
like I guess you'd call them hippies,
maybe the green hippie guys and uh,
I say stuff as I was talking to him,
like,
so trying to have a rational conversation
and they were saying stuff like,
okay,
so if we want to have a
neutral carbon impact,
we have to chop down a forest the size
of the Indian subcontinent and then bury
that on the ground every year.
I was like,
that just doesn't seem like
that doesn't seem rational.
Like that doesn't seem like a real thing,
you know,
like the,
like this logistically speaking
like I wouldn't be possible to do.
And I don't think it makes a lot of sense.
What do you think of that?
But I'm not.
And he said just to remain
neutral as we are now,
that's what we'd have to do.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Um,
you know,
the whole idea of,
you mentioned you used to be,
you know,
in favor of revolutionary,
um,
anthropogenic action to anthropogenic
put to what people claim is anthropogenic
climate change climate,
you know.
Yeah.
It doesn't,
doesn't necessarily.
That doesn't necessarily,
uh,
it may not necessarily work in a,
I,
I've heard from somebody that,
you know,
after nine slash 11,
the,
um,
after the planes were grounded for
like a week or something like that,
the,
the average temperatures,
the average temperature a higher,
you know,
it got hotter and scientists initially,
if I'm remembering this correctly,
were kind of panicking wondering
what the hell's going on,
why is it getting hotter?
And then they figured out that,
oh,
the aerosols that we put into the air,
the emissions from the planes was,
is cooling the earth.
And you know,
at this point,
you know,
they came up with A.
I don't know if that,
at that point they came up with the
global masking effect of a global,
a global dimming or
aerosol masking effect.
I forget which it is.
Um,
so it seems like,
you know,
it's a damned if you
do damned if you don't,
but you know,
with Australia,
you know,
now this is just,
it's another tangent,
but somebody in the chat said,
scientists are forced to lie.
Carbon tax is a global theft scam.
Well,
I don't necessarily know that because
the Australians were forced to that,
those funds that they were being taxed at,
you know,
if whoever was taxing them necessarily
thought that they were actually going to
get their shit together,
you know,
put their brain power
together and develop,
you know,
more innovative
technology so they could drop their costs,
you know,
maybe the,
the uh,
uh,
the,
not litigators,
but the legislators thought that we're
just going to get money from them now and
you know,
that turned up not being true.
So I don't know that,
you know,
it's,
I don't know that it is or
isn't a global theft scam.
But there again,
you know,
because I don't know,
I think there's a country in
the world where the taxes are,
you know,
what you pay is transparent.
I forget what country,
I mean,
you can look it all up online,
you know,
to what extent that's truthful,
but,
you know,
I don't know that money's
necessarily spent wisely.
I don't,
I'm just ignorant of all that and
I just want to think tangents.
But
I think that the,
uh,
the way the carbon tax is
proposed is it's sort of like,
um,
like a moral tax,
like you're doing it
to help save something.
But I think the problem with
climate change and I think that the.
Obviously the climate is changing,
it's just hard to pin
down exactly what it is.
Like there's these correlations and
I've heard all the arguments about like,
oh no,
it's definitely,
um,
humans or whatever.
I understand your points,
but it doesn't seem to,
uh,
it's not,
it doesn't convince me because there's
a lot of historical records of climate
changing as well.
And we weren't burning
fossil fuels at those times,
but all ultimately I think that the
question is just so much more complicated
than,
than the sort of portrayed it to be.
And to me that just speaks to it being
a little bit that they're being a little
bit dishonest and I'd rather than be more
open about what the reality is rather
than just saying,
oh no,
just trust us,
we're the experts.
And that's the,
if you hear someone say,
trust us,
like we're the experts.
That's like actually a logical fallacy,
argument,
argument from authority.
And um,
that doesn't really convince me.
I mean,
I would,
I would like to believe them,
but,
you know,
have you,
had,
I,
I had,
I brought up
any assignment had I brought up any
potholer 54 his videos to you before where
he basically,
I just missed that.
Sorry.
It was a resolve messed up.
Had you had,
I brought up pot full of
potholes or 54 to you before.
Um,
and his basically debunking
of the Heritage Foundation's
that you've seen on the
circuit of mainstream media.
There's a couple of talking heads and
a Lord Monckton was one of them and he
basically takes,
because he's,
because he's a journalist,
he does it effortlessly,
um,
and shows you where they're pulling
their data from and how it fits into this
larger picture and shows you
the larger picture all on,
you know,
uh,
the,
reference.
Um,
I don't know the term,
but the scientific literature
literature is the right word.
But,
uh,
and it just,
I didn't have to go back over it,
you know,
to be able to make an argument.
I'm kind of ignorant so I really
shouldn't have an opinion on it.
But,
um,
it seems like to me,
yeah,
I believe that,
that,
you know,
the,
the projections aren't necessarily true.
Uh,
the,
you know,
I've heard Peterson say that the farther
the projections are out because they're
using what algorithms so using,
you know,
uh,
estimate estimates.
Yeah.
They're using a basically algorithmic
models to project out and they don't.
And the,
all the data doesn't
necessarily know it's static.
I think.
I don't necessarily know
that these algorithms,
they're not dynamic.
You know,
you put input in,
you get output out,
you can't put input in and then
factor in all these wherever you can.
I don't,
maybe I don't understand
how algorithms work.
Um,
it was almost like trying
to like regulate the market,
right?
Like it's just so many inputs and outputs,
you know,
you don't really know if
you've made a mistake.
Where did you make the mistake?
Right.
Yeah.
I'm just knows optimistically skeptical.
Uh,
she,
uh,
whoever that spirit are here,
but they mentioned the Bjorn
Lundberg's a documentary.
I just listened to a talk a talk with
a human Jordan Peterson and it really
changed my perspective on the whole
climate change issue because a pound for
pound or dollar for dollar you
can make a lot more impact,
uh,
on human suffering.
If you say put money in
one place versus another.
And climate change is like one that's
way down the list that you could do to
make the world a better place.
Yeah.
Well,
so,
uh,
but he's,
he's,
I think he's onto something there and I
think he's very convincing to a because
it makes it,
it's the climate change argument is,
Oh,
let's save all the poor people that
are drowning in the rising oceans,
but realistically,
I mean,
there's a lot more things we can do.
Yeah.
I don't think the,
uh,
the rising oceans are too serious too.
Some of the climatologists like a,
there's a climatologist Paul Beck with
out of Ottawa that I listened to whenever
he puts out new videos
and he has a problem with,
uh,
some of the models and the problem
that I've noticed with him.
Um,
the problem that he has that I've
noticed is some of the models,
they're,
they're not as specific
as you'd like them to be.
They don't go back as
many years as they should.
Um,
and because I can't reference anything,
what I'm saying is,
you know,
it doesn't even matter,
but I mean,
if you watch some of Paul beckwith's,
a newer videos,
um,
you know,
it,
he's basically talking about
these atmosphere of models and a,
him just wishing that
they were designed better,
that they should be designed better
because they would give you a better
indication of what they actually mean.
Um,
he,
you know,
he himself,
I think he's mentioned that,
uh,
you know,
he and Paul Beckwith is a firm
believer in geoengineering.
Uh,
and,
you know,
it makes sense that as,
if these carbon taxes do
force companies to innovate,
if you take out aerosols from the
air according to these climatologists
arguments,
uh,
and the global,
the global masking effect,
the Aerosol,
the global dimming effect or
the aerosol masking effect.
Um,
you know,
you make the Earth Cooler and
if you take these aerosols out,
you take pollution out,
the earth heats up.
I mean,
it's,
that that's a and these,
you know,
that wasn't necessarily a model
that it's not something that,
I mean I think that
should be tested again.
I mean to what extent it
was enough definitive proof.
I don't know,
but I,
but to scientists,
it was really weird after nine slash
11 when all the planes are grounded and
then,
you know,
United States that are the global
average temperature shot up and uh,
you know,
they,
they coined that I think around that time
and he,
I guess like I said,
Paul Beck with is a firm believer in
or engineering and I don't necessarily
know,
you know,
what that means and you know,
what affects those could have,
you know,
what those,
whatever particulates they,
they plan on how they'll administer that,
you know,
it's just um,
but there's a target,
there's a lot of climatologists
I believe in June.
It jus engineering.
So,
you know.
Yeah,
I mean,
I totally understand.
I don't totally understand Bjorn
Lawnburg I didn't see the whole a video,
but yeah,
it makes sense that if you want to
improve humanity that maybe you should,
um,
that yes,
other things are more
important necessarily
than trying to deal with climate change.
I mean it seems like we don't have a full.
We don't have a full
handle on the data yet.
I mean there's no,
I don't know.
And the funny thing too is if you had
mentioned like the fact that the data is
not really a,
I guess you could say
exclusively inconclusive,
then they call you some sort of a denier.
Right.
But the thing is when you seek,
when we want to know the truth,
they,
I guess that's what everyone says,
if you're denying their sort
of ideological position.
And I think this climate
change things almost,
it takes on like a flavor of like almost
like religion but not like the good
parts of religion,
just like the dogma.
Um,
so I have,
so I have this theory,
I kind of have to go into it to explain
what I'm getting to with this climate
thing.
But,
so you have it with religion and all
really ideological belief systems.
You have the dogmatists and he
had the spiritualists and uh,
the spiritualists,
um,
I guess this is kind of,
I kind of took this from Peterson,
uh,
so the documents,
they really care about the structure,
right?
And they care about order and
they care about the 10 product.
Then you have the spiritual,
it's that kind of like more cared about
the trend or the metaphor or like if you
were to break it down politically.
We live in a liberal society mostly,
and we have liberals on the left and
we have conservatives on the right.
And that's the two wings of liberalism.
The spiritual,
the liberals are the spiritualists
and the conservative side is the,
uh,
the dogmatist and you need
both because if you don't have,
if you go full spiritual,
you become like fundamentalist,
right?
You can become so chaotic that,
that nothing that,
that structure breaks down essentially.
And if you go too dogmatic,
you can be freer.
Society.
So you don't adapt,
you're not adapting to change
and society starts changing.
You need to adapt.
Um,
so with these climate scientists,
uh,
at some point they were spiritualists
because they believed in doing something
to better,
uh,
to adapt,
but at some point they
adopted a more dogmatic,
a s,
a good spirit but,
or a dogmatic way of being a
in terms of their ideology.
And now if you even doubt it,
it's like you're doubting the
existence of God if you're a Catholic,
you know,
it's like,
it's that,
that intends to these people.
So that's where I think they've
said at some point that happened.
I haven't been,
I haven't pinpointed
down to who do you mean?
Oh,
who do you mean?
Like for who?
Who would be the spiritualists?
Yeah,
because the climatologists
that I listened to,
you don't really,
uh,
there's only,
if,
actually,
sorry,
I can't say climate Tajik because not
all climatologists but the like Potholer,
I mean they don't,
they just basically
Kinda will refer to the,
refer to the literature and right off,
you know,
until there's evidence or until
somebody can actually make an argument.
I'm a correct one where,
uh,
because a lot of the,
a lot of the people who are
claiming that it's not real
aren't even citing the data that
is put out already properly.
I mean,
the data's already being misinterpreted
and mishandled by the people when you
see the mainstream,
when you see it in the mainstream media,
um,
immediately it's being mishandled it,
so it's not even there.
So it's like the people who
were saying that it's like flat,
like who were saying it's not real,
aren't even using the correct data.
Are you there?
Straw manning what has always
been considered a climate change?
It was a theory that was a,
it was a,
a theory that was proposed I
think in the late 19th century.
Uh,
and so if there's just,
it's,
it seems like it's,
there's just a lot of wrong.
I Dunno,
I don't want,
you know,
I don't know if I wouldn't
say the scientist are
necessarily like a spiritualist
themselves,
um,
or document this,
uh,
but I think a lot of the followers grow.
Yeah,
definitely.
No,
I agree with you wholeheartedly there.
And that's a problem too,
you know,
I mean,
that's like you'd probably run in,
you've probably run into people like that,
like in her daily goal in your
life or just like they were like,
no,
this is the truth and this
is the truth as I see it.
And if you don't agree,
then you're a bad person
and you're immoral.
Honestly,
I don't,
but I don't think
I've had that happen.
It's like walking on
eggshells around these people.
They're like,
probably,
if I was in Chicago that
would happen a whole lot more,
you know what I mean?
You don't know.
I,
I take that back,
you know,
that is the case sometimes that
there's very few very few issues.
I just think everything
is murky around it.
It might happen,
it might happen more to me,
11 of stuff,
frankly closer,
but might happen more to me because
I live on Vancouver Island and it's
notoriously full of hippies.
And uh,
so,
uh,
and I think maybe that might
have had something to do with it,
but I was.
Maybe in Florida it's
not so bad or I live,
it's just this like hippies
and lumberjacks and then
you go like some stuff in
between.
But those are the main two populations.
Yeah.
Oh,
you know,
if you were to bring up Christianity
in any way and try and challenge that,
that would be a big thing in the south.
You get a lot of uh,
no.
This,
the truth said,
well,
what do you mean?
What do you.
I don't want to get into all that,
but uh,
yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
Just seems like everybody's
mishandling the data.
The scientists are too shy.
Uh,
you know,
some of the,
one of the scientists say that no,
the,
you know,
everybody's had that climatologists
err on the side of conservatism.
I mean,
they're,
they're trying to be
conservative with their,
uh,
their views.
But then again,
like the models don't,
don't necessarily add up.
And one of the guys who was heralded the,
uh,
the most,
I forget who he was big in
the seventies who predicted,
you know,
large scale and he's still harold,
that you predicted large scale famines.
Uh,
just all of this,
this the single guy,
and he was like a guru to the climatology
movement and most of his stuff ended
up not becoming true and uh,
and there's still people who,
you know,
but,
but that's another thing is that,
you know,
this kind of tologist beckwith,
they'll say,
we don't know what happens when the
positive feedback loops start happening.
Like it could be a really
slippery slope and it will be,
it will,
it will start happening so quickly.
And whether that means,
you know,
within five,
10,
20,
30,
50,
100 years,
whatever those timeframes are,
because it seems like
nobody can model this out.
Nobody can predict.
Well,
uh,
you know,
one of the guys who's a real alarmist,
um,
you know,
he's really concerned with,
the sea level is rising,
not a big deal.
You know,
what I'm concerned with is just the
slight increase in heat changing,
uh,
changing the,
the,
uh,
the effects on Farnam
changing based off of,
in our ag,
in ag or aggregation aggregation society.
That society.
We don't look at Grit.
Yeah.
Well,
our agricultural being affected by a,
you definitely being affected by
the slight increase in heat and,
and that the,
basically the famines will start happening
so quickly that people like myself,
you know,
uh,
I starve,
you know what I mean?
There's no,
uh,
assistance and that assistance,
emergency support for people like me.
You know what I mean?
I'm in the states is pretty,
um,
you know,
all man for himself down there,
it seems.
Well,
yeah,
the state will vow will,
Vive will vie to protect itself.
But you know,
what,
this guy who's saying,
I'm concerned about
agriculture being affected,
which,
you know,
I immediately think of,
well,
we have a company called Monsanto who,
you know,
of course,
there's shady practices and
they've got a bad history,
but they've created,
I assume they've created
drought and heat resistant
plants are,
they're doing that all the time.
Like I used to be one of those people
that would like maybe protest them.
Uh,
but,
uh,
but not that I ever went to a protest,
but they,
they,
uh,
they've definitely changed.
They definitely become more,
um,
like scientifically.
Like,
people are always like worried.
I go,
what do you want the meadows,
the salmon genes and the river.
I'm just like,
okay,
well I thought that might have been bad.
But now I looked and I looked into it.
The scientists,
I'll say,
well,
I guess actually serious,
no trouble at all.
The No.
So,
so they,
they have some problems for,
for,
for sure.
Like they,
you know,
one second.
So the kid was crunching up a,
a plastic bag,
so I'll just tell him to shut up,
shut up.
But um,
anyways,
so,
uh,
yeah.
So,
uh,
yeah,
things like Monsanto,
there's good and bad things about it,
but hopefully that some of the good
things were that we were able to adapt.
Like for instance,
do you know anything
about the norse history?
Like the Vikings and
stuff on the Greenland?
No.
Okay.
So,
so they were in greenland,
right.
And they could grow crops.
At the time it was like
barley and they wrote,
they were raising sheep and stuff at the
time that was like think up until 1400
or 1300.
They were doing that from around,
uh,
around a thousand 80 and a,
maybe slightly before that,
or they have all these settlements
there and they're able to survive.
They had like several thousand people
living in Greenland at the time,
which,
you know,
I think getting greenland now,
even with all the modern technology,
that's like 40,000 people or
something across the entire,
the entire place.
So there,
but then it got too cold and by $1,400
all the settlements had to be abandoned
because they couldn't grow anything.
And everyone needs,
you're starved to death row left.
Not that there's any written
records except for uh,
you know,
some,
uh,
stone squares that are basically that
remain remain remainder is like arctic
archaeological digs,
but um,
to climate change so faster in the
medieval warm period to now that like,
those settlements basically got wiped out.
All that was left was the nun
who didn't settle anyways.
They're always moving around hunting
the animals that were on the move.
Right?
So even in that short period,
we could see there was a
climate change and even now,
but back then they didn't have,
like,
we weren't burning oil and
massive amounts of oil and thought
it would be.
It wasn't any different than it is now.
So what caused it,
right?
If it wasn't those two things,
it could be that,
that's the problem.
It could be a myriad of other things.
Uh,
it's another thing is like,
uh,
when I mentioned potholders,
like he'll,
he'll go over into a lot of these
timeframes and it'll show you that,
like this,
the science is settled and it's
clear and this is what happened then.
And I don't know exactly why,
you know,
I'm bringing up right right now,
but I'm not sure that.
Yeah,
well maybe,
maybe,
maybe he's right.
Maybe he's right.
I don't know.
It's weird how he just,
like,
he,
he just fled because he's a journalist
and because he's been a journalist for
uh,
I forget exactly what,
um,
he just comes up with this information,
insights it and,
you know,
and he timestamps,
exactly every part of the video
where he mentions anything,
he'll cite it and it's
timestamped citation and so
you can look it up and it's,
it's just,
it's really crazy because until I saw
until I saw him present some of the
information,
it was much more.
It's like nobody,
I have never,
I haven't seen anybody do it.
Uh,
and the reason,
that's the reason I bring up potholder
so much is because it's like Jesus
Christ,
this guy,
it's,
it takes him no effort to just dispel,
you know,
uh,
the Heritage Foundation.
I mean,
you know,
uh,
I don't know how much money,
you know,
the Heritage Foundation.
I don't know what,
you know,
they're our think tank.
I don't know how they get your revenue.
Maybe I would say think tank.
Uh,
probably get donors.
Yeah.
Um,
but,
you know,
he's dispelling a billion.
Maybe it's because they don't
try so hard because it's not a,
it's just one of the things on the agenda
to manipulate and for whatever reason,
you know,
you don't,
who knows why.
Maybe it's because,
you know what,
we don't want to put the effort in
innovation right now that we have these
things,
you know,
I'm just speculating obviously,
but,
uh,
I dunno if it's coherent,
the speculation that,
you know,
maybe it's that we don't want to tackle
climate change right now because there
are other things are,
you know,
are,
the donors businesses are being
affected by this right now.
Time for this.
You know,
one thing,
I think you're Lumberg was saying that
you can spend a dollar on a family
planning for third or develop women in
developing nations.
I think you'd get a return of 120 bucks
every time or 60 bucks or something like
that.
Every time you spend $1 on that in terms
of like overall economic value in this
is all done by a large group
of independent economists.
Um,
and then you get climate change and for
every dollar you spend on mitigating
climate change,
now you'll get about three to $4 in value.
Right.
Okay.
So like you could do way more,
have way more of an impact,
like more bang for your buck if
you spend it in the right way.
And I was thinking,
okay,
well I,
I,
I'm gonna and they use the most
extreme climate change scenarios.
Like they always go when,
when they do those
calculations they do it,
but for the most extreme.
So I'm basically,
it comes up all these recommendations
for like how you can spend your money
best.
And after I looked at them like,
well,
okay,
climate change,
let's say it's the worst possible problem.
There's still like,
you know,
way down the list.
And I,
I don't,
I would probably,
uh,
if we,
if,
if I thought that what if we got to do
something who would definitely fix it?
I would definitely be okay with that.
The problem is I just don't feel confident
that like you can get the results
that they say seems to be speculative.
Yeah.
That's the thing is that the climatologist
I listened to or this are the same
way they're not.
If we,
if we take action,
it will fix it.
It's like,
well,
maybe we think it will.
We know that immediately that,
you know,
we spray aerosols in the air,
the average,
you know,
the temperature will get cooler,
but you know,
they don't.
Then they don't say that.
They don't then say that.
What we don't know if it
will always get cooler,
you know,
I think the,
they're conservative.
They don't want to say that.
I think a lot of people just are like,
well,
we don't really know what is
necessarily going to happen,
you know,
and what,
and that's just you.
You bring down the temperature.
Okay,
so you stop a blue ocean event where and
when you stopped the permafrost melting
and the methane being
released into the atmosphere,
you stop all these things,
but you know,
what happens?
Uh,
no,
I don't know.
Can the aerosols that
the geoengineering hey,
have a negative effect.
I mean that's a
or what happened when all
that nothing comes out.
Does it have the effects that
they say it's going to have?
Yeah,
that too.
I know,
you know,
I,
I mean obviously,
you know,
in a,
in a micro environment,
yeah,
methane will kill you.
But,
you know,
in the macro world,
what does,
what effect does that have an eye and
paddle or my one over that and some of the
other climatologists I may have went
over that and I'm not able to remember.
Uh,
I'm shit at retention.
Um,
but,
um,
yeah,
I just,
I don't know,
it's a really weird issue and uh,
I really had a lot of admiration
for Peterson when he said,
uh,
you know,
we don't really know what
to do about it and even if,
you know,
unless we all do,
I don't know that it is necessarily
said unless we all do something,
it doesn't matter.
Um,
but that's the truth.
I mean,
it seems like we just don't know that,
you know,
there's like short term things
fixes that could eventually have,
you know,
other problems later,
you,
you trying to solve something
and you just create problems.
You know what I mean?
That's,
so,
that's almost always
the case with anything,
uh,
you know,
not always,
but in a lot of ways,
you know,
you create a solution and you know,
you then there's unforeseen problems
when you impact them in.
Yeah,
I dunno,
it's like a,
this is like a total sidetrack,
but cameras you have like immigration,
how like there's,
it's sort of like the view we get a bit
from one side and the other is usually
very myopic.
Like it just gives you sort of one,
one narrow view,
uh,
then on the right and then they have
one narrow view on the left and see,
you don't really get the,
you got to really narrow
view of the entire,
like say broad spectrum of,
of the issue.
Um,
like for example,
like they say,
okay,
well our population is declining so we
need immigrants to help buttress the
engine system or something.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
Because there's a lot of the
left doesn't make that argument,
but at the same time they'll say like,
okay,
well,
uh,
to many people's bad because
it hurts the environment,
know.
Um,
uh,
and then the right,
we'll say,
okay,
well it also hurts Roy.
It's waste,
which is weird because the right also
says it hurts workers rights or workers
like ability to market their skills now,
but at the same time I think,
I think it does in certain fields
it does definitely in the trades,
um,
because you get a lot of illegal workers.
Uh,
I mean it's,
no just said,
paused for a second there for some reason.
Oh,
well I was,
I was saying that it does
affect the trades I believe,
but it affects employees
in the trades and effects.
Uh,
I think people on the lower,
a lower part of the totem pole of,
of income.
Yeah.
Lower income jobs,
low lower income,
self employed jobs too.
I mean it's harder to break out when,
you know,
illegals are
able to work for,
you know,
so cheap under the table.
Well that's the thing,
is it?
No,
that's the thing.
Is that illegal?
See,
I've had illegal friends
and they pay taxes.
Taxes are taken out of their checks.
Yeah,
that's not a uh,
oh,
they just don't do
their taxes or whatever.
Uh,
no,
I think I'm pretty,
you know,
that's a,
that's a good question because I
don't necessarily know about that,
but I could ask my,
my,
uh,
not necessarily right now,
I haven't spoken to him in a while.
My friend Christian who and a Lei
Ha and I can't talk to another guy,
but you know,
I've had quite a few illegal
friends and every single.
Yeah.
And they pay our taxes
than I did at the same.
It was pretty crazy.
Yeah.
And so the whole idea of illegal
is not paying taxes to me,
maybe true in some,
uh,
in some cases,
but that's certainly not
true across the board.
I mean the irs doesn't give a
shit where the money comes from,
but it's coming,
you know,
you're paying into social security and
your pain in your paying an income tax
and if,
whether or not you're a federal
income tax and whether or not you,
uh,
whether another is a state income tax,
you're paying that too.
Um,
yeah.
But
I don't know.
Yeah,
there may be ways around it,
but people that I knew that it didn't,
uh,
yeah.
And yeah,
many also work under the
table and there's also that.
Yeah.
Um,
I don't necessarily know that all those,
that,
the whole trade thing is true,
but I know that,
you know,
illegals work for less,
they work longer.
They don't necessarily produce
the same quality of job.
But in the building industry,
you know,
it doesn't matter.
You know,
Dr Horton is a,
probably shouldn't bring that up.
But
uh,
yeah,
so there's this employers,
employers,
uh,
make a lot of money off of quick,
cheap,
you know,
acceptable work
and uh,
yeah,
well there was going to try the companies
that I was going to try to make the
most amount of profit I guess they can,
like.
And there's nothing
really wrong with that.
It's just what they do.
Yeah.
Um,
so like if you can,
if you're just looking at it like a,
you know,
you're trying to be,
I don't want to say it's hard
to put this little words,
but you're looking at just like
as if you're like a gray face,
neutral vehicle of power
trying to manifest wealth,
then all you're going to do to say,
well,
what,
what's the input and what's the output?
So am I going to input five
bucks and get 10 bucks in value?
I'm going to input seven bucks,
10 bucks,
and they don't care.
They'll just go for the one that
goes to some of the most value,
right?
Right.
So,
so they,
they don't,
don't want necessarily discriminate if
they can get away from away with it.
So whatever the,
whatever the rules allow for,
they're just going to go for.
And the rules aren't being enforced.
That just means the rules aren't,
don't have to worry about them.
There's no rules that have no
power behind them are worth plus.
So if the state isn't x,
what do you call it?
Deporting people that are illegal,
then,
well who cares?
They'll just hire them.
You know,
doesn't make a difference
to them ultimately because
ultimately they're not the
one that didn't think wrong.
They're just looking at the
labor markets of free market.
The states,
it's really open that way
and they just hire whoever.
Like in Iceland for example,
in order to work at any job,
you need to get some like government
id and the end you need to like,
we registered that then and then when
you get a new one join a company,
you automatically joined the union
that's associated with that line of work,
which is another weird thing because like,
usually unions are like free association
and all the unions are essentially a,
they'd negotiate separately.
Oh,
with her or like her.
It's like all the guys that we're going
to fast food restaurants while the,
not just a,
I'm just making this up because I,
I don't know the specific example.
For example,
all the plumbers will be in the same
union and everyone has to be in that union
affair.
Palmer,
right?
Um,
but in,
in the states you can be,
you can be your own plumber,
like you can have your own business.
Um,
he can be part of a
company that's unionized,
we part of the company
that isn't unionized,
so that changes from state to state.
But yeah,
that's true.
Some states are full union,
like a
in areas like,
uh,
Indiana is a,
I'm not sure exactly how it works,
but it's a,
it's not a right to work state.
It's a,
at least for some of the trades.
I don't know how.
I don't know exactly how it is now.
It makes sense,
but it would,
it would vary.
The states are very,
very different between each one.
Yeah.
In Florida,
in Florida,
there's no unions in Illinois and Indiana.
It's heavily unionized.
In Indiana,
especially
for there's no unions.
Well
or very few.
Yeah,
probably very few.
I don't know none,
but there's no,
there's no
let me maybe south Florida,
Miami,
but you know,
some people considered south Florida be
almost a different state because of how
you know it,
it just doesn't like North Florida,
central Florida,
West northwest Florida or the don't
compare at all compared to the,
uh,
we can get to the economic generation.
Did the income generation
of south Florida.
None of them compare Florida carpet.
I think there's a,
I don't think there's a
Florida carpenters union.
Uh,
I remember the,
uh,
I'm actually a member of union myself,
but I don't really have
a choice as the IBW
that inter national brotherhood
of electrical workers.
Yeah,
they do have a union,
but guess what?
It's in south Florida.
It's in Tampa.
Orlando,
I guess we'll land is
still considered central,
but that's where the,
that's where the money's at.
I mean,
you don't have money.
Well,
what's the penalty like anyways?
Have heavily military.
I mean it's.
Oh yeah,
it's a,
you know,
Eggland Hurlbert with
your air force bases.
Tyndall was an air force base,
but it was just destroyed
by a hurricane Michael.
Um,
and then you've got duke
field which is an army a.
Then you got it.
You got a navy base here.
I mean it's
the majority.
I honestly believe except for
like the resort coastline,
like destin 30 a Panama city,
parts of Pensacola,
you know,
if it weren't for the
middle of your living in,
in the areas,
then this wouldn't be the type of
area that it wouldn't have the same
development that it has,
like in 2008,
you know,
it didn't see the same,
didn't.
I mean everybody was affected in 2008.
Uh,
you know,
everything got tighter.
But,
you know,
I think the military really helped
this area kind of move forward.
Yeah,
it helps.
Oh,
uh,
yeah.
I,
I have a buddy that lives in mobile.
I think that's pretty close.
That's pretty close to the pan on Alabama.
Yeah.
I've driven through
there a couple of times.
That's cool.
I was doing.
Do you ever do any answers?
The research I've ever done that A.
Yeah.
Yeah,
a little bit.
Not so much as submit blood
or anything like that,
but uh,
or however that works.
But yeah,
I know a little bit of a,
you know,
my father's side,
their family came from Italy
as dad's and mom's side.
It was,
had lived in the states here for awhile,
so I don't know where in
Europe they came from.
Um,
and then my mom's side mom was British,
so maybe you brought that
up for different reasons.
I shouldn't just start rattling off.
Oh no,
it's fine.
Yeah.
Uh,
I just,
uh,
I was a lot of family
that came from the states,
like North Carolina,
like a western North Carolina
and like northern Arkansas,
another origin.
And I was because like,
um,
apparently one of my grant,
I got my grant,
my mums,
dads like great grandfather,
great,
great grandfather.
He was apparently like a slave
owner at some point and uh,
he sold as slaves before the war ended
in New Orleans and then move and move
yourself a Yellville,
Arkansas and buried the gold there
because you sold them for gold.
And uh,
I was always a,
I know the location of the farm and
I was always curious like is he.
They said he forgot where he buried
it so it might still be there.
So I was like,
oh,
I wonder.
And I looked at the Va,
it was $30,000 of gold at the time,
which is like 2 million bucks now.
Oh Wow.
So I mean I feel like I'd feel,
I feel kind of bad,
but
you should,
you should search it out.
I'd look for it.
Yeah.
I,
I gotta,
I gotTa kind of location by that I mean
the study looking for a needle in a
haystack,
right?
Yeah.
It may be worse.
I mean if you have excavating equipment
or the types of machines that you could
find things in the ground,
you might be able to find it.
I don't know.
Or I could buy the farm.
I think I could buy the farm for
120 grand then just start digging.
But yeah,
I've done a lot of interesting
research to over the years.
I traced some of my family,
like I trace my family back there,
my dad's mother.
So my grandmother,
her grant,
her father's mother,
I traced her family back to England king.
Uh,
it was like the maternal
grandfather of a ethelred,
the unready.
It was like the King of England.
Yeah.
Which is pretty cool and I think if most
people were to trace their family back,
you'd actually find those links because
it really expands.
So for example,
you know,
you have to give to parents,
right?
Then each one of them have two parents,
so then,
so you have four grandparents
and so on doubles every time,
10 generations and you're like a thousand
up to a thousand unique ancestors,
which is actually really,
which is really unlikely.
You'd probably have a lot less because
there's like some inbreeding that happens
at that level.
Um,
you'll probably find that at some point
your parents or some level of cousin.
I'm like sixth or fifth or later,
you know,
usually not closer than that unless it
was like some sort of pathology going on
in the area.
But uh,
like I was,
I was able to.
So my parents,
they or their family's origin from
completely different parts of the gay.
Um,
but I found like common
relatives between them,
which is really weird that I've done.
I did the math on it because you can't
really locate because they show up as not
related.
Right.
But you can find people that
are related to a share like the,
like they share like a
third or fourth cousin or,
or later.
Um,
and from there you can see like,
okay,
well if they shared just if I shared
this much with them and they share that
much with them,
that means they were related at some
point so you can kind of triangulate from
there.
So I found it.
My parents were like 7:38
cousins or something like that.
It's an estimate,
it's an estimate.
But you'll find that the people are like,
oh that's kind of fucked up.
But then you find out that they're
probably even closer related depending on
where they lived.
Right.
So like if you lived in
the same county in England,
your chances of being like
third cousin or closer?
Actually quite high.
So I guess it's Kinda
Kinda get some kind of.
But third cousin though you're like
basically not related like a all,
like you might not even match with them.
So at that level it's not really that bad.
It's the main problem.
The major problem with a cousin,
I guess you call it sanguish,
consanguineous marriages is like,
for example,
in Muslim countries,
they made their cousins a lot like
first in Pakistan especially I think 50
percent or 40 percent of the marriages
are like second cousin or closer.
Um,
so what happens is if you,
so if you marry your cousin,
you have kids and your kids married
their cousin and this happens,
right?
You look a compound.
So the regular rate of
like genetic disease,
I think if you just made,
if you have a kid with some random
person from the other side of the world,
it's like three percent.
But if you're,
if you're like in a line of first
cousins that kept getting married,
it's like 12 to 13 percent.
I think it maxes out.
Maxes out ABS are at.
So,
uh,
with these small towns in England,
do you use to get a lot of these problems?
But then when they started,
like,
uh,
so when they went to the states,
there's not like a lot
of English people there.
So they'd have to like Mary,
like Spanish or French or
Italian or Irish or whatever.
Whoever was available.
Right.
The market is quite different.
Yeah.
So you got like a,
that problem sort of sort of started
to disappear in the new role.
But in the old world that kind of still
happens like New Zealand and stuff too.
But uh,
yeah,
it's been uh,
it's,
if you ever get the
chance to look into um,
your ancestry is kind of interesting
because you find out a lot of stuff that
is,
if you don't find it out in sort of store,
it is this kind of knowledge
that gets lost forever.
Yeah,
definitely.
I didn't,
I hadn't ever looked into
it a to know that much.
Well,
I found my great grandfather who was kind
of a strange because he had like three
families and my grandma,
my grandfather was like
in his second family,
he just kept like abandoning families.
Um,
but I found out that he had
like two different colored eyes.
So I was like,
okay,
what's up with that?
Apparently it's like,
it could be time Arizona,
which is a think I'm going to
talk to you about this last night
because I have like a split
brain or something like that,
but I was,
I was curious like if you had
tried mannerism and his brain was,
you had a split brain,
if that was related to the,
uh,
if that might've been the reason why
I kept breaking up in this family.
It's like leaving.
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't remember.
So I was just being often optimum and
yeah,
it was just popped.
It popped into my head.
But yeah,
I found out where he was born,
like within 100 meters
and a in Scotland though,
I'm only actually a third,
third generation Canadian.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Uh,
I think,
uh,
exactly.
One,
two,
three I think would the second or
third generation American from my.
Yeah.
Your grandparents,
your grandparents were born in the USA.
You'd be third?
Yeah.
No,
they were born.
They were born in.
One of my grandparents were born in Italy.
One of my grandparents
was born in England.
One of my grandparents was born here in
the states and another one was born in
the states,
one in Illinois,
close to Lincoln and one of them,
uh,
in West Virginia.
That's cool.
Uh,
the earliest ancestor app is
like someone that was born in
17,
76 or something like that in Virginia.
So it was my earliest relative,
but,
uh,
in,
in North America anyways.
Yeah.
But no.
Any other topics you want to talk about?
I got some more if you're interested,
but I have to pull them up.
Yeah.
Uh,
if you give me a sec.
Are you going to use the bathroom?
I'm,
Oh yeah,
sure.
Just give me posted if I can say I'll
see if I can fill the air for you.
Okay.
Just a minute.
Alright.
So I'll just read off this thing.
I wrote,
history is said to be
written by the victors,
but really the history is
what?
Sorry,
I think I fucked this up.
History is said to be
written by the victors,
but really history is nearly
written that history is written.
That history,
which is written is where the
sentence should end written history.
Can never represent exactly
how events occurred.
It can never be purely objective.
It is instead.
Subjective history is in
fact written by the writers.
It cannot be any other way and must be
considered in perspective and thought
about within context.
It's contextual.
Standing media as we see it today is
written in much the same manner that media
cannot construct objective
reality through its storytelling.
It is only possible to construct a
subjective reality in the written word and
doing so creates a narrative tail which
at some points is accurate of reality,
but in others less so.
Why does this matter?
Because we were told that the
narrative is it self our reality
that is however mostly untrue.
It is no more true than to say that one
subjective experiences are the totality
of our collective experience.
This cannot be said to be true
because each individual experience a
differentiates to some
degree from the collective,
which isn't really an experience a more.
It is a collectivization and
narrative retelling of a certain time.
You cannot have a collective objective
experience because anything you attribute
to a collective neither accurately
describes reality for any individual.
Nor could it possibly described objective
reality for a group of individuals.
That is not to say that the narrative
narrative has no place at that.
The narrative cannot describe
that objective reality.
A narrowed,
however,
is important because it allows
us to transfer information
and knowledge into the
future and to have this.
It's whatever it gives
it gives it one weakness,
which is the weakness we must all look
out for when we investigate and learn
about our history.
Both the strength and the weaknesses
of the written word lay in the writer.
The truth is that history,
it was never written by the victor.
It was merely accepted by the victor.
It was instead written by the scribe.
Even though you may being
the scribe of the victor,
it was nevertheless written by him.
It is true that the victor ad been
unaccepting of described work.
Uh,
if,
uh,
if he had been unaccepting of described
where he could have altered the written
narrative,
but how could the victor possibly
understand or know or foresee the future
interpretations of the
narrative subscribed?
The truth is that the victor could not
foresee how exactly future generations
would interpret the scribe history.
So it is possible.
We are the descendants of the history.
It'd be interpreting it
differently than our ancestors.
Yes.
Especially the spirit of the written work.
One might try and argue that the present
narratives are more reliable than past
ones.
Not The reliability only
reduces by a narrative age.
I consider that this isn't the case.
What can we infer?
Homework,
contemporary media
if they're in their narratives.
Okay.
That's all I wrote.
So a partial.
Are you,
are you back?
Oh,
it must be just turning the knob.
That was kind of kind
of blabbering on there.
I wasn't quite finished what I was doing.
Yes.
History is definitely
rewritten for the uh,
uh,
he was definitely written by.
Well,
it depends.
It can be rewritten by the current victor
and that's certainly the case,
but
yeah,
header chromia.
That's what my,
uh,
I just looking at the chat now
as what my great grandfather had,
um,
he was actually,
he's,
he got sent off.
You get registered on Vancouver island
to fight in the Canadian expeditionary
forces.
Which went to Siberia.
That helps stop the Russian
revolution or the assist.
The white army.
It's the ribs.
Uh,
I guess I missed failed
because they came back.
I'm in a rush and I
have all his documents,
a pay stubs and stuff.
From that time I thought
it was pretty interesting.
So that's the history we don't
know about a lot in Canada.
So
it was cool to see.
But I found out he had three families.
First he that he came from Scotland.
He married a Mexican woman named Maria
and they moved to the Seattle area.
And you had two children.
Uh,
they got divorced,
she got the children,
he moved away,
met my great grandmother and Alberta,
Alberta,
Saskatchewan.
Her name was Alberta.
And uh,
then he had three more kids with them.
Um,
but before that happened,
my great,
great grandfather who was his dad,
uh,
one to know where the
hell his grandkids were.
So he went to a Seattle and
found them in an orphanage.
But the sun,
the,
there was two children,
son was younger.
He was adopted right
away by another family,
so he couldn't find them.
Uh,
but he found the daughter who is older
and he brought her back to a Saskatchewan
and basically just dropped them off
with my great grandfather and said,
dropped her off my great
grandfather and said like,
you're take your damn kid.
And uh,
so that my grandfather ended
up growing up with this,
uh,
his older half sister or then when
he went off to war to stop the doll,
I guess during the depression
slash world war two,
um,
money came back to you is she was gone
and I had divorced her husband and uh,
I guess taken the four boys that
she had had with him and he went to,
she went off to try to find
her brother in Seattle,
will never did married some random dude,
another guy and end up dying in Arizona.
Two thousand five,
the four boys.
I'm not sure exactly what happened to
them there from the first marriage of my,
just my great aunt.
Um,
she,
um,
I think one of them ended up fostering
a second cousin of mine that lives in my
town and I was able to find
her through 23 and me and um,
I went for coffee with her and
stuff and it's interesting.
She didn't know she was adopted though,
so,
uh,
if we kind of gave her a
heads up about her family,
I'm back.
Hey,
what's up?
Oh,
so I,
I,
it,
I ran out of the thing I wrote,
but uh,
it wasn't,
I didn't realize I hadn't finished it,
so when I got to the end to
just kind of trailed off,
but,
uh,
so exactly a what.
So how do you know that
your dread third generation,
third generation?
Does it?
Do you have to consider
all your grandparents or,
or is it just.
Yeah,
traditionally you go by your father's
father's father sort of thing.
You kind of go down the a paternal line.
So whatever your name is,
Becky,
whatever you.
It wouldn't have to be your
father's line neighbor.
Like you could,
if you had your mother's last name,
for example,
you could go by that,
but it says generally by
what your last name is,
because I mean otherwise,
otherwise you'd have
10,000 different origins,
right?
Yeah.
But that was different.
It depends on the tradition though.
So,
um,
but my,
I know my family's tradition
as a is a patriarchal.
So.
But you'd go by the,
uh,
father's last name,
most western societies or anything?
Yeah.
Oh,
uh,
like,
for example,
Jewish society is,
I think they go by the mother.
Oh,
okay.
There's a good reason for that too,
because if,
you know,
if you're,
if you,
the reason why the juice side is
filled by the mothers because uh,
um,
you know,
for sure that you're Jewish
if your mother was Jewish,
but you could be fathered
by some random dude.
Right.
So if they don't think that
they traditionally they
don't see the father as the
reliable progenitor.
Yeah.
So that's why you get these,
like these memes,
or like a Jewish mother is always want
their sons to marry a Jewish woman so
they're can have Jewish grandkids.
That's what,
that's what that's all about,
right?
It's just,
it's kind of like we
all make jokes about it.
Yeah.
Why don't you marry Nice Jewish girl.
Oh yeah.
It's interesting.
Or at least different
traditions that people have.
Like the native Americans.
I think they have a different one as well.
They're more about like
the grandparents parents.
Yes.
My,
my great grandfather,
he would be from a.
you'd be from Italy,
Bari Italy.
Do you know which part?
Yeah,
a Bari Aria.
Which is that the north or South or south.
And it's on the,
uh,
east coast line.
Okay.
So the opposite.
So my wife's family's from Calabria,
which is like or Calabria.
It's like the one that's
like the toe of the boot.
Yeah.
Okay.
I guess here's the heel,
right?
Yeah.
Okay.
The east side of east,
south,
east side of it
for south east side of Italy.
Yeah.
That's cool.
Do you know how long
they had been there for?
No.
Uh,
I don't know how long
they had been in Bari.
I've wondered about that,
but that's irrelevant.
Hey Kid,
probably you could probably figure
it out if you went to a church there,
contribute visit about the
church that your family went to.
They probably have records if any
warehouse then it would be there.
Really?
Yeah.
I'm like,
if I go back to the Netherlands,
I can in Scotland,
I can get records for my family as far
back as I said there's a written record
anyways unless there's a fire.
Um,
but uh,
I just don't have the
money to go to Scotland.
Just know.
Yeah,
I didn't know that.
I'm glad you told me about that.
I don't have the money to do that,
but it's kind of Nice to know that.
Yeah,
that
that's available or possibly available
if it hasn't been destroyed or discard it
or it'd probably be there like if it's
your grandparents that were born there
and if you have their
full names or something,
you could probably any
knew where they lived.
You could probably figure it
out like within a day or two.
But uh,
it just,
it depends if they're a
registered and all that stuff.
But yeah,
that's crazy thing.
Like so much history.
It just wasn't written down like
there's so much missing now,
like nowadays,
like you're going to have pictures of
yourself when I at every stage of your
life and your great,
great,
great grandkids might be able to like,
look at it.
Right?
The way records are kept.
Yup.
Assuming the survey result don't get wiped
barrier than underground under
a sheet a lead or something.
Um,
I forgot what I was going to say.
Can't remember.
We got to check the chat.
Any questions here?
A picture?
Who else do you?
Um,
basically the goat.
It's not my daughter again,
like this.
Uh,
yeah.
I'll take any questions you got
or what questions do you want?
Want me to answer?
I'm reloading my page.
I think it froze on me.
Oh yeah,
same thing.
Alright.
Steve Nichols.
What do you got for me?
Anybody who's got a question?
Thinking.
Okay.
Uh,
on the meantime I'll try to
find something that I wrote.
Uh,
I wrote this a
thing.
I guess I could maybe
pull something from it.
Um,
okay.
So I read this thing.
I could give you the first paragraph
or whatever and see what you think
we did discuss it or whatever.
Yeah,
yeah,
go ahead.
Okay.
Alright.
So I'll just read the paragraph and
then I'll say it's done or whatever.
Uh,
I often consider certain prescribed
ideas which counter orthodoxy.
I'm not certain why I do so,
but I think it's because they used to
fall into such orthodox will thinking to
some degree anyways,
the questioning alleged authority
figures seems to be a part of my being is
fiber.
Perhaps I speak truth,
but that would seem to
sell for grandizing.
So best to avoid believing that holy as
it risks falling into similar modes of
thinking in regards to truly knowing that
is to say overconfidence towards one's
limited knowledge for as a rule once
knowledge is by definition very limited.
That was the first paragraph anyways.
Um,
so what,
what I was trying to get up there was
um,
I come across people that have
these sort of stone ideas and
Orthodox Orthodox ideas and they don't,
uh,
they're kinda like in movable.
And I find that.
What was,
I wrote this because I started thinking,
well,
why,
why are they these kinds of people that
don't want to learn new things or why
don't they want to consider even just
entertain the possibility of a different
idea?
So I started writing about that.
Maybe have you come across this,
uh,
you know,
I,
somewhat with the whole
dose,
the Truth Candle.
I mean,
I thought the name when I picked it up,
it really didn't.
It really wasn't like,
oh,
it's not really my dosage route.
The dose of truth is Jordan Peterson,
you know what I mean?
It was,
uh,
this,
like he was the one who is
shedding new perspectives and then,
you know,
then I got into,
with titling videos,
um,
Peterson would meet something and then I
would take some interpretation and then
unfortunately not provide any commentary
to be able to explain what I meant.
Um,
so,
you know,
people be like,
oh,
this is not that,
this is what this means.
And,
uh,
but I mean in everyday life,
yeah,
I,
you know,
I certainly try and stay
open about everything,
you know,
I just assume most of the
time that I don't know.
No,
I just assume most of the time
that I don't know what the hell.
Yeah.
Well if you're open to learning,
that's always the best way that I
approach things because otherwise you just
become too uh,
oh,
you liked the humility,
right?
To learn?
Yeah.
Uh,
yeah,
I come across
people.
Yep.
Who Do you have for who definitely
like dead set in their beliefs.
Um,
but you try and ask them why
and they'll try and argue from
like a moral standpoint
rather than any type of,
you know,
rational
standpoint.
Yeah.
Oh,
want me to go into a second paragraph?
Yeah,
yeah,
sure.
All no problem.
I got like,
it's like,
I think there's five paragraphs.
I don't read them all and this,
I will work through respond anyways if
we even do they get boring world to stop
because I don't want to.
Definitely not boring.
If anybody's boring,
it's okay.
So the difference then between arrogance
and wisdom and and also when I'm
writing this,
I'm like,
just like thinking out loud,
like reading without like really I'm
kind of rewriting this without really was
kind of rough draft.
Right?
I just want to say that
before I start going off,
I'm sorry I said that I.
I go on the difference then
between arrogance and the
wisdom is both in at least
some part wisdom that is to say
experience and landscape passage.
You have to think about that.
I mean to filtered biases in
a truthful and honest manner.
Now,
removing biases or biases
may not be possible,
but it is possible to be thoughtful about
them and perhaps experiment with one's
capacity to hold a thought in one's mind,
in which one does not necessarily hold
as part of their personal philosophy of
life.
Perhaps this capacity to emphasize,
empathize with others is what allows
one to really understand other ways of
thinking and in order to truly see
them as valid or invalid based on their
genuine merits rather than rhetoric.
I currently have you rhetoric as a co,
as comforting lies rather than what
purposes are what their purpose does are
supposed to be.
That is to convince
people using information,
whether the information is valid
or invalid doesn't seem to matter.
Some believe in very wrongly,
in my opinion,
that data recorded can be pure rational
evidence of a known problem and thus
guide us toward the
solution to solve problems.
That's my second paragraph there.
Can you repeat the last sentence?
Oh sure.
But you're back there.
Some belief and very
wrongly in my opinion,
that data recorded and be pure rational
evidence of a known problem and thus
guide us towards a
solution to those problems.
So what do you.
What exactly do you mean by that?
That data recorded?
Well,
I think that some people see like they
pick like a say two plus two equals four,
therefore that means this,
right?
And they think they're being objective.
So
that's hard.
The
they think they believe
that they're there.
They're subjective interpretation
of data is objective because they.
Because the data's objective itself,
like Duplos do,
does he go for it?
But that doesn't mean that when
you apply it to real world,
um,
that means that like,
I know a goat's milk is better than
cow's milk or something like that.
This is some random example,
but they might see that the actual raw
data as the proof of bias of their bias.
Yeah.
I'm here.
I've probably done it.
I mean,
I'm not that I'm not intelligent and
certainly not edgy and educated very well.
So I think,
I think everybody does even like,
you know.
Oh yeah,
the most elegant of this.
Yeah.
I don't,
I don't know that biases by Caesar,
you're a
can be eradicated.
IREC edible here
can be.
I can renew it reconcilable
now that irreconcilable
you do eradicate,
eradicate.
Is that your radical?
Yeah.
You're asking eradicable that
sounds good to me is a tough word.
Yeah.
Well it shouldn't be unless
it was a fucked up language
is I think era era.
And that's like,
uh,
the,
the uh,
the first part of that word is more of
a little Latin or Greek origin in the
second half of that word is not,
it's like a dramatic origins.
So it's like,
it's almost a Portmanteau oh,
that's another thing I'm
really interested in too.
I'm interested in etymology
and like different languages.
Yeah.
The origin of words.
Etymology.
Yeah.
Entomology is like the
origin of words and how,
how they're formed or the,
the how are they came to,
they came to be a,
their origins and like other
languages and such like that.
Yeah.
Like a,
like English is only like 10
percent norse for example,
like based off old norse languages,
but like the words that we most
commonly use are all norse.
So like what are words or pronouns?
Most of the are,
um,
which I thought were
they say 50,000 of our
birds are French in origin.
But like that's just kind of a
stupid thing to say because I'm,
a lot of the endings are the same like
reception is of French origin work,
right?
So it's perception when a exception,
they're all French origin.
So,
I mean,
they're not words that we
use everyday or not everyday,
but in every sentence,
like,
although words are used in every or from
like the Nordic languages in Germanic
languages,
you know,
despite the fact that we're,
we're still largely
influenced by the French,
the normans invading
England back in like 10,
66.
Yeah.
Lacking when it comes to history.
I know one thing is,
uh,
when I took German in high
school all four years,
uh,
I remember
my first year,
probably within the first couple
of weeks I thought to myself like,
man,
you didn't,
you didn't pick up
anything as far as like,
yeah,
you didn't pick up much as far as grammar
goes because I basically relearned
grammar in high school
through a foreign language.
Like I.
Yeah.
And it was weird.
Yeah,
it was like,
man,
I'm so dumb and I didn't pay
attention or for whatever the reason.
But no,
it's actually like the
philosophy that they,
how they teach English.
No.
Uh,
what your,
what your rebar?
80 seven.
[inaudible] 88.
So we're pretty much,
we're in the same era.
So,
uh,
but they did back in the nineties
or maybe it's the late eighties,
it started teaching English.
They used to teach English,
German and French now,
and they decide to say English
has two artistic of a language.
So they don't want you
to learn inorganically.
They want you to learn it like naturally.
So they took away all the,
all the pointless,
pointless,
but all the structural grammar stuff
like you learned in weight when you're
learning Spanish or French or
German because we learned French
and Spanish.
Uh,
but,
uh,
yeah,
I had to learn all that stuff again
in French and French is like at way
different language than German.
Like the way they structure it,
they don't use case cases
and such a big deal.
Um,
so when I tried to learn an Icelandic,
they have case just like in German,
then it's like,
it's like it's just as
complicated as the German one,
but we never,
we never think about that in English.
We just,
we just do it,
you know,
like you don't think,
you don't think about pushing the
gas pedal really when you're driving,
you just do it.
It's like that,
but in German it's like you,
you need to know that shit.
Otherwise you don't know
what the fuck are you doing?
Yeah.
You don't.
Uh,
genitive dative.
Nominative accusative.
Yeah.
I'm forgetting all.
Would they finished?
Finished?
Has 14 cases.
Well,
something like that.
Yeah.
I,
my whole thing was like,
uh,
I don't think languages
are very hard to learn,
but then again,
I don't think anything's
necessarily difficult to learn this.
You just put time and effort
and that's unused move.
If you never use it,
you lose it.
Yeah.
That's like my brain.
I
kind of wonder sometimes about A.
I kind of wonder sometimes about,
you know,
what people mean maybe because they
hadn't ever learned the language when they
were younger.
I'm like learning language.
I couldn't imagine doing that now.
Or people say that,
you know,
when you get older,
I don't know how old or what people would
age people are necessarily referring
to,
but you know,
I guess I'm fortunate now that I think
even if I was to try and learn language
now I,
I still could manage.
It may not be as easy,
but
yeah.
Oh,
I think,
I think actually as I've gotten older,
I think I've,
I could probably learn it easier.
It's February,
I never got a chance to use it.
Like I can say some things and
a lot of different languages,
but like the fact that I speak basically
exclusively English and just a little
bit of Portuguese.
I'm a real shame because like,
but that's the thing,
what if I started using
Portuguese all the time,
like I'm not going to use the Icelandic
and if I use Icelandic all the time,
not going to use the
Portuguese all the time,
so I'm going to lose something.
Yeah.
So I,
I just consider it like,
um,
something I just do just to be just a,
it kinda gives you a different
way of thinking too if you,
if you can learn a little bit about
another language and if you don't like
become,
if you can read a little bit,
that's good too.
I think it just gives me like a different,
another brain,
you know,
you're,
you're not,
you're certainly right about that.
I mean,
uh,
okay.
So I worked for a metal fabricator for
awhile who was from Poland and the way
that he would sometimes structure
sentences or say things like,
and I don't know exactly how they're help
Polish or whether it comes from or how
it's structured,
but I think,
I think you've been frozen
or quiet that I missed.
I missed the last,
like three,
three or four seconds that.
Can you hear me now?
I can hear you now.
Just say it went okay.
It went.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
so yeah,
I think that in interacting with
people from foreign countries,
uh,
that I've been able to understand
them better based off of
or.
Yeah,
for my learning of German.
Um,
yeah,
I totally agree.
When you learn another language,
it provides a new perspective.
You think of thing,
you think things differently.
I mean these are all things that
I've thought about in the past,
uh,
you know,
as pluses to having learned German and
it's got to be pluses of just learning
languages in general.
Yeah.
Like,
um,
uh,
I think you,
are you still there?
I think I'm going to have.
Yeah,
I'm still here.
Okay,
just making sure,
um,
I think for me,
like I went to Iceland so I was okay.
Well now
that made me interest.
I went to,
for all my first trip I went to,
I went to Russia and I tried to learn
some of the Russian language when I went
there I was a student,
uh,
I think it was like 17 and it was,
it was really awesome because like,
you've got to meet all these Russian
kid like kids my age and they really
appreciated the fact that I give,
uh,
gave her a whirl,
you know,
so like I worked so
hard on this one phrase,
I can actually still remember it.
It's like I can say like,
do you understand Russian or,
or uh,
I,
I can say,
do you understand Russian or I going to
say I understand Russia and then I get
to the negatives of those so
I don't understand Russian.
And so,
but I really worked on those.
So I,
I still remember him
today and I'm like 30.
So 13 years later I still haven't had.
Um,
and then Icelandic,
I learned a bunch of different phrases,
but the weird thing is when you're trying
to learn language on your own is like
the sound,
you always have the sound off because
you don't have any way to bounce it off
of.
So when I got there I was trying
to tell them where we're at,
my hotel or hotel,
but like,
like an airbnb or whatever it was.
And uh,
I was saying like loud good deller,
which is like,
that's Nice logo there and uh,
that's how you say it.
So,
but,
but the,
it was interesting for me because
in English it's like very simple.
Like the pronunciation for
me is like really easy.
Even if someone has a different accent,
I could understand what you're saying.
Yeah.
But for this guy,
because it's a totally different language,
I don't know what the different accents
are and he doesn't know what my accent
is really.
So I have to say it like
15 different ways to.
He's like,
oh,
lower there.
And then I'm like,
okay.
So it just was unexpected things
to happen with the colloquialisms.
Yeah.
So if anybody wants to know how to say,
uh,
I understand Russian and Russian,
you say you have putting me up.
Yup.
One Mile public want to say I don't
understand Russian is young attorney of
myopathy skew and say.
Do you understand Russian has
been funding mates it school.
If you say you don't understand Russian,
we say when the Aponte mice you posted.
So no bravo.
Learn something new
on the pod podcast.
Yeah,
it's pretty cool.
But yeah,
Iceland,
exit.
Cool language to originally the
vikings apparently would just like,
there was no word order.
I guess there was no official word order
so you could say it like as long as you
have the words in the right case,
you could say you could
say the sentence any way,
which I guess helped when they
were writing like poetry and stuff.
Um,
but
so I could take,
I could say a couple things and I sign it.
I just can't think of
something to say right now.
I'm like,
it's a big.
If I could say my name is.
So is he.
If Haiti,
if Haiti liquid,
you know,
or uh,
uh,
go on to say what's your name?
It's a native food.
What are you called?
Both,
but I think it was English is so
close to Atlanta because like through,
right.
That's for us the you a success,
the second person a single and if,
if it's English.
So you would say though,
right?
That's what the original one was out.
So that one through or visit the same
word and you can find once you know that
there's all these cognates,
it's like way easier
to learn that language.
It's very hard to pronounce a lot of the
words because sometimes the words are
like German where that's like,
you know,
16 characters long.
But uh,
you know,
eventually figured out what.
That's just a bunch of
compound words put together.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
German borrows from
Spanish French.
Sorry,
I missed that.
German has words that borrowed
from Spanish and French.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
Right.
Actually,
I tried,
I tried to learn German while
when I was a kid because my dad's,
one of my dad's girlfriends
was Germanic and origin.
She was from like West Germany.
Um,
but,
uh,
I can't remember.
I can't remember much else.
I was like 11 or something.
So I've been really absorb it very well.
Yeah,
I,
uh,
so uh,
I always found it interesting like a,
if you're from northern Germany,
you know,
more posture and it
would be like your eyes,
like if you were to say a
like,
I am German,
isn't it?
If you're north,
Jeremy is eat,
eat,
and it fits in South Carolina itch.
Uh,
so you got time.
You can kind of tell,
you know where a person's from based off
of how they just say their eye or you
know,
c,
h,
you know.
Yeah.
That's an issue.
It's if,
if it had been or if,
if,
if an unbeliever.
Yeah.
Oh,
so I didn't get notifications
for dose of truth and Youtube,
son of a bitch.
I kind of wished that I would
in my third year German,
my junior year we were,
our final was to create a,
because we were reading the brothers
grim.
Oh really?
You're reading the
brothers Karamazov no care.
Uh,
the brothers Grimm fairytales
that the groups were,
all the fairytales
actually originated from,
from the graphic gruesome tales
that were told to the grim grim.
They like,
they wanted them down too because they
were even more gruesome than they wrote.
Yeah.
And uh,
so yeah,
so our thing was we'll create a fairytale.
It doesn't matter.
You can make it as graphic as you want
and I can't remember what I made mine,
but I wish I still had that so I
could know so I could bring that up.
But.
So sometimes I try and remember words or
you know,
I'm not,
I can't,
as far as the grammar goes,
now I would have a hard time remembering,
but it was like,
um,
like
the window is black.
Uh,
the window is a feminine defense.
The defensive shots don't know.
There's just like people,
like you have to kind of say something
like asked me how to say a sentence and
maybe,
you know,
I'm just coming up with
things off the top of my head.
Don't work that well.
I'm Canadian and I ride on a boat.
Uh,
soup is to train a
boat,
is a skip or shift been als Canada wound
each have an end and I wrote on a boat
or I.
well,
I wrote it down.
Yeah,
you should have an I'm each Hubba.
I'm on nine
boat.
Uh,
what would be the past for a,
you're a
good riding sacred,
right?
Yeah.
Good ride.
And even then it's not a verb
isn't past tense.
I was like,
uh,
then then the verb and then
Ian or something like that.
Well,
it's a,
I think we'd be like,
have a on.
I'm something.
Something good,
get in the verb,
gift far and,
or,
uh,
give live in or a need or a
yeah,
it always comes at the end of the gift
slash verb always comes at the end when
you were asking or when you're talking
about past participle or past tense shit.
Yeah.
Past tense.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
Uh,
yeah.
I was good at at one
time and I spoke it well.
Do.
But
man,
it's so,
it's worthwhile looking into once in a
while I'll just refresh your mind to it.
I think it kind of,
it keeps your brain thinking.
Yeah.
I'm not going to ever hurt,
right?
No,
it can.
You don't do it enough.
Yeah.
Can hurt.
It can hurt a little bit.
Yeah.
No,
but you're right.
It,
we can never hurt to keep learning.
Um,
yeah.
Okay.
So I could bring up the number of the
idea I was talking about yesterday about
the,
uh,
a resentment towards people with
massive wealth and the isn't,
it's not something I wrote about it,
but I just want to make sure it's a.
okay.
I'll just read it from the start.
There's a snobbery long.
Um,
so everybody,
this is just an idea that like,
resentment towards people
that hold a massive wealth,
uh,
the people that are mad
that rich people are,
they are,
they got nothing.
Fair enough.
I understand that.
But here's something I
wrote about that idea.
Let's think about some guy
who has made something useful.
If you want to give me,
if you want an example,
I'll use sit,
say Bill Gates because it's easy now.
A bill didn't really do a whole
lot according to the cynics,
but as well with a his boss would
show otherwise for what it's worth.
He revolutionized personal computing even
though he just reebok's other people's
shit together.
Built becomes a billionaire,
blah,
and here we are today.
Why was he allowed to accumulate all
that wealth so much wealth in fact,
that it'd be impossible for him to spend
it in his lifetime and his own anyways,
that seems unfair and it maybe it is,
but he was the one who was
initially rewarded for this
innovation over the whole
society,
benefits from his innovation
regardless and over time,
the entirety of his wealth and
return to the entirety of society.
Eighty percent of inherited wealth
is gone by the third generation.
It could be up to 90 percent,
so now with the amount of relative
freedom compared to the past,
we can see a huge gap between
the richest and the rest below,
but all those rich people have created
their fortunes by developing new ideas
and tools and whatnot.
That's the infrastructure over time that
just becomes part of everyone's living
standards.
And so and so,
they rise in totality over time.
However,
there is a delay issue.
It takes a few generations for
that totality to accumulate
in the bottom portion
of wealth distribution.
A good example,
another one might be Isaac
Newton's Principia Mathematica,
no one you or I know is making
money off of that information,
which is just book he wrote on physics
because it was so long ago that the
knowledge has become part of the
overall societal infrastructure.
So when we're speaking
of wealth redistribution,
we're really speaking about doing a boat,
doing so about doing so more quickly,
but that creates a huge problem.
By doing so more quickly,
you might end up removing that
incentive to do things at all.
You might,
for example,
see the lack of development
in places like the SSR,
which really began to lag behind
the west quite dramatically.
If we removed the ice,
that incentive,
which if you look at it generationally,
uh,
is a very low price to pay,
we might end up removing the increase
in living standards over time,
which of course will only be harvested
fully after three generations,
three generations.
Which if you remember approximately
how long the ceasar lasted.
That was,
that was the end of that one.
I have nothing else.
Yeah.
What do you,
what do you think of that?
Yeah,
I,
I find it more interesting that you type.
I mean,
you,
you kind of talked about it yet,
you did mention it yesterday.
Uh,
the,
the idea that,
you know,
you have someone that comes
from someplace or you know,
wealth is generated,
you know,
you have
migrants that come over,
they work hard,
you know,
typically three generations down the line,
wealth is lost.
I was only applying that to a immigrants,
but I,
but you know,
you helped me realize that that's a.
am I right in thinking that that's,
it's true across the board
that typically when a,
when wealth is created
within three generations,
it's lost.
Like just doesn't have to be an immigrant.
Yeah.
So I didn't know that.
Um,
so,
you know,
when you mentioned,
uh,
you know,
Russia's a,
the USSR,
you know,
falling,
yeah.
Their,
their,
their economy was the size of
California in the 19 eighties.
That was before the tech boom and stuff.
And then even now Russia's economy
is the size of a New York state,
which is quite dramatically
different than the USA
and that they only lasted
for about three generations.
Meaning that the meaning that they will
probably a feasting on the wealth that
had been,
you know,
previously created
as a new scenario in a creation myth
where the Anunnaki feast upon the body of
absolute.
Yeah.
That was interesting.
It can't be done in perpetuity because,
uh,
and this is obviously from Peterson
because he talks about this,
but um,
so if people are familiar,
a Marta is the one who
eventually overcomes time at.
But in the beginning there's absolute
and time at and the children and they're
called the Anunnaki and they kill a
absolute of boredom and feast upon his
corpse and party and stuff.
And that pisses off time at obviously,
and then you know,
the story,
eventually they come to the trend defeat
time and the only one that eventually
does is martech and he creates
the world out of her pieces,
which is a story,
uh,
renewal.
And one thing we see with the baby boomer,
maybe not all baby boomers,
baby boomers and millennials,
is they want to feast upon
the corpse of absolute buy in.
And they symbolize this through
the idea of eating the rich.
And this is often seen
in communist ideals.
And the problem with it is that you end
up at the same issue in this scenario
mythology where if you
try to feast upon what exists now,
you'll eventually run out and then
you won't have innovated and in your
solutions to your problem of starvation.
Um,
no
a metaphor that one,
but,
uh,
you end up at the same problem that the
Anunnaki came work we're going to face,
which was the chaos dragon,
which is symbolized by tying
that in the scenario and myth.
Um,
so what is wrong is they
try to feast upon the,
uh,
that.
Well,
I guess there's ours and that wealth
dependency runs out at for some time.
The USSR did grow,
but they're not at the
pace of the USA then.
Sorry,
go ahead.
No,
I was going to ask you,
why do you think that that's.
You already mentioned that it,
you know,
it's among the baby boomers and
other generations in between even,
I mean,
you didn't say gen x,
but,
uh,
the millennials to,
you know,
do you think that that's
kind of happening?
That's happening now?
You know,
obviously,
you know,
it's a generalization
that is happening now.
Well,
if,
it's kind of funny because if
you look at a concierge test,
she is like symbolically the Anunnaki,
like she's like the mouthpiece
of the Anunnaki and what,
she doesn't realize
this because she's not,
well,
she's not well educated
or at least in terms of like mythology.
She's not well educated,
which is a huge mistake by the way.
Everyone should,
like,
that's a mistake I
definitely made growing up.
I should have learned more about this.
But,
um,
she's not well educated
in these mythologies,
which is a very big detriment because
you can learn so many things are so deep.
But yeah,
she is the mouthpiece of the
Anunnaki side of that story.
Um,
so,
which unfortunately she probably won't
be alive long enough to learn because it
takes several generations to
devour a course metaphorically.
She might not be around to even see
the damage she's going to cause moving
forward.
Everyone else has moving forward.
Right?
So you're going to be behind,
right?
Yeah.
And uh,
you know,
who knows what,
um,
you know,
who knows what,
how China feels about
no her and
what China.
It's like they're eventually,
because I know they're close,
they're much closely tied to us then,
you know,
then a lot of people,
I see a lot of people who do,
I mean,
I don't know.
Well,
what's the problem with China is like
they have to spend so much money on
enforcement cost,
um,
though they are extremely
highly productive.
But I think eventually they lose.
They're going to lose that momentum and
people are going to start wanting more
freedom.
It might not happen,
but that's my guess.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
I've just kind of derailed the thing,
but I definitely think that,
you know,
they'll lose productivity at some point.
I mean,
if people don't stand up then that,
then this is then you could just
see soon as rope.
What as robots come in,
they're done like as soon
as the robots are really.
They're pretty widespread now,
but as soon as they're like
the main productive capacity,
like you can build them in your backyard.
Like China's going to have no,
no economy.
I mean not any more than we go.
What,
what do you mean as far as
manufacturing or doing anything?
Sorry,
sorry,
I missed the first.
After the first.
The first part of that
question is blanked out in,
uh,
in what capacity?
In every capacity a well,
in terms of like,
like right now what?
You know,
how they make all the consumer goods?
Yeah.
In manufacturing cars.
Imagine if you had.
Imagine if everybody knew what
a three d printer like never.
I need to buy any like dollar stores
spatulas you make one at home.
Then eventually,
I don't know if everyone will have on,
but eventually they're going to be so
cheap that almost everyone's going to have
one.
So maybe you won't have a three d printer,
but your neighbor will.
Yup.
Hey,
can you make me a special though?
Just like,
you know,
in the old days you'd ask for
a cup of milk or something.
Yeah.
Okay.
So that's a special something.
What about in
terms of like,
um,
no,
I think that drivers will be replaced.
I mean most of the drivers.
Yeah.
Every everyday.
Almost every day I'm on the road.
I mean I drive pretty conservatively.
I drive with a decent length among the
next car and it's always paid off in
terms of me getting through lights easier.
Being able to maneuver
around car is easier.
Like writing a person's ass is
bad many more ways than just,
Oh,
it's stupid as fuck in many
more ways than just being a,
the opening yourself up to a car accident.
It's just so much more
efficient to leave room.
But I mean,
well anyway,
and then when I saw that,
you know,
computers have a,
have analyzed exactly what
the most efficient traffic,
pat the most efficient traffic,
what the most efficient traffic flows
would look like in the United States if
cars follows a certain pattern.
And it was typically the length that
I leave and I'm thinking myself like,
yeah,
you,
I mean people are always driving.
So anyway,
so what I'm thinking is like,
I pray to God every day that it
maybe not commercial drivers,
but people just have more
cars taken away from them.
I mean just,
it's because it's so inefficient because
people lose hours and days just driving
cars.
I mean,
thank God,
you know,
Elon musk is digging tunnels
to help at some point,
alleviate traffic.
Uh,
but yeah,
so,
but I mean as far as truck drivers go,
like that's not really a good thing.
I mean,
truck drivers,
you know,
I don't always understand
how they're doing things.
I mean sometimes it seems
like to be an assholes,
you know,
they're communicating,
it's hard to really know.
Um,
but you know,
to take their work away,
that'd be terrible.
I mean that's
either reminds me,
uh,
so yeah,
I just meant in what capacity.
Exactly.
Because like robots,
I've,
I've heard people say if
you can keep that thought,
I've heard people say that
the,
uh,
are the hockey stick,
is the hockey stick effect as it has
been applied technology over the last
uh Huh.
Last 10 years or so.
Like with computers and everything
is not going to resemble
well,
like,
like robots do not learn on the same way
that the humans develop computer chips.
That's what I've heard technologists,
scientists say that it's,
no,
you're not gonna have the same.
Oh,
you know,
in 1990 year playing shit.
I don't know.
Wow.
Well,
with the,
with what I've heard from some people,
they say that like,
yeah,
events chair at some point the algorithms
are going to be developing ways of
improving themselves without our knowledge
or like in ways that we won't be able
to comprehend or lex faster than
we're able to catch up in terms of our
comprehension.
So I'm not,
I'm not quite sure.
I think eventually,
unfortunately almost all trucking
jobs are going to be automated.
Yeah.
Which is like so many people
are employed in that sector.
Yeah.
But I don't necessarily think
that's true fully because I.
because again,
like they're saying that robots are so
bad at pattern recognition right now and
it's not this like the,
the scientists don't see
it as this effect where,
oh,
we're suddenly going to know how to make
them more efficient or better pattern
recognizers.
This is what I've heard that yeah,
the trucks will drive
themselves up to a building,
but then somebody with
the capacity with the UN,
with the skill set of backing a truck
up to the loading dock is gonna have the
takeover because right now robots don't
have that capacity because they don't
have that ability to do that effectively.
They're not able to
basically doc
with the traffic and so I think that's
the thing that will eventually solve that
issue,
but I don't know.
I don't know enough about it to be honest.
Yeah.
But I wonder if that'll
leave in our lifetime.
I mean,
I don't necessarily know that that's.
I don't think we'll see.
We'll see that in our lifetime.
I mean,
may see,
I think on the highway.
Yeah.
I think on the highways you'll start,
you'll start seeing like automatic trucks.
Do you remember that movie,
Logan?
No,
that's the wolverine movie.
It'll last for the last war room.
Okay.
Well there's like this in
the future and they're like,
I made a comment.
Oh,
I hate these auto trucks because
they're just driving around like not.
They don't really care.
I don't pay enough attention to the road.
I guess they're just doing the
transportation job and they have no cab.
It's just like a,
almost like a big box on wheels.
Yeah.
Um,
but I saw that.
I'm like,
yeah,
I guess I saw that and I was like,
oh,
well I guess that looks pretty real as
stick when that could happen really soon,
unfortunately.
Because,
I mean my brother,
a driver and a,
well you don't want to see them at work,
but will,
you may still have it.
You may still see people
travel with the truck,
but they may just be maintainers rather
than drivers and they may be emergency
drivers too.
I mean
because one guy or one guy's
in charge of driving 10 inch,
like making sure 10 trucks make it across.
Right.
Instead of just having one eye,
I can see that happening for sure.
I think it will be a gradual thing.
I didn't mean that we won't see
trucks automated on the road.
I met,
I don't,
we won't see widespread,
uh,
enough for automation is already there.
Pretty much widespread.
Like there is one area that
I don't agree with a c,
so I grew up in the Chicago land area
and Mcdonald's headquarters in Oakbrook,
Illinois and in Bolingbrook,
Illinois,
a town over from where I lived.
I'm not,
I don't know about this
restaurant specifically,
but
it,
they,
they would,
it got to a point.
It was the same Mcdonald's
for years and years and years.
And then one day they decided to make
it one of the flagship restaurants,
meaning that they will tear
that restaurant down sometimes.
I think
one time they did it six months apart,
so they tore it down,
not for nothing.
They didn't get the whole,
they didn't demolish the building,
but they gutted almost everything
in the inside the exterior.
And then six months later they did it
again and all of a sudden you've got
kiosks where you just,
you don't have to go up to a person.
They had automatic cheeseburger makers.
I mean,
so,
you know,
there are already automating things and
I heard someone say that you can't do
that and it's already been done.
I mean it's already a.
So you know,
to the extent that I think you
can phase all the people out,
I don't know enough about that,
but I just don't think we'll see it,
you know,
as widespread.
And then if there's other problems,
you know,
you start putting people out of work,
will that have a negative effect
on technology and progress?
And I don't know,
there's some crazy like a for sure.
That's nice.
Maybe like the first area they'll uh,
the
really get down as in warfare that wave.
So when people do get out of work,
you know,
you're not,
you don't have to put boots on the ground.
You got robots that are policing people.
I don't know,
it's a
go full skynet,
I hope.
I don't hope they keep
their shit together.
Oh,
another one thing I'm seeing yet,
that starship troopers book that
we're talking about earlier,
I'm part of the history is that they,
uh,
earth is like,
there's this big war between the
West and China because trying to get,
get so powerful economically.
And this was written in the sixties.
So this guy was pretty oppression.
Um,
but,
uh,
so for anyone who doesn't know,
a starship troopers is
written by Robert Heinlein.
I highly recommend reading
the book and Washington movie.
But anyway,
so there was a war with China and uh,
I think they don't really go into details,
but it sounds like the west won that war,
but it was against this totalitarian.
I'm sort of robot sort of ideal.
I'm sorta like how China
is doing now with their,
uh,
their morality system with
like the points black,
like the Black Mirror episode,
which is kind of fucked
up because that's like,
that's 1984 is something
that you could kind of.
Everyone was guessing
I was going to happen,
but this is almost like
brave new world style.
Like in China you can go around
talking about tenement square,
but it's just only if you start like
doing big speeches and in influencing
people then it's a problem which
is not completely totalitarian,
but it's just to tell Terry
enough to keep things,
you know,
the way it is.
Yeah.
And when you mentioned brave new worlds
board that know people accept and
uh,
accepted and well too preoccupied.
Yeah.
And there will be welcoming the uh,
the social credit system.
I mean,
I don't know that everybody does in China,
but I'm sure there's quite a bit of
people don't know I'm talking about.
I don't really know anything about it.
I just know that it
sounds scary and to that,
I mean,
you kinda got it here.
You know,
Alex Jones can't say
the shit that he says.
So are guns gone off Patrion?
I mean we don't know really how far
this goes as far as I understand.
I think as long as there's free people
willing to stand up and say things,
I think we're probably,
we're going to be okay for a long time,
but we definitely have to like keep
raising the issue of being able to say
things because uh,
for example,
I find myself censoring
myself on reddit because I'll,
I'll,
if you try to pose,
if you're not a left wing person,
right?
Because right.
It's like 10 to one left wing and you go
on like our politics or like one of the
main world news or something like that.
And you say anything that's
outside of the left is orthodoxy.
You're just downward you
downloaded out of existence like.
So you Kinda have a reluctance to say
those things then because the more you
downloaded it down with a lot,
eventually you just can't post at all.
Yeah.
So it,
it creates like this fucked up system
or things kind of need to be said like,
you know this like Oh,
trump's going to be indicted because
of this guy said something disguised
cousin's barber brother said something
and trump's definitely gonna get caught
this time.
Right.
And it's been going on for two years.
Every single posts like that gets like
30,000 or more votes and it's like it's
complete garbage because like it's Oh,
maybe it isn't,
but it looks every single
time it's the wrong.
Right.
So I've basically filtered it
out in my mind is pure garbage,
but it's still good,
like $30,000.
But that's because it meets
the leftist orthodoxy.
They've actually,
they're like,
well this maybe it's exactly how I think.
So I'm an upload it.
But if you make,
if you'd comment on there like,
come on guys.
Like really this is like the 400th
fucking article you've uploaded to 30,000
votes and it's never worked
out to be what it says.
And you just get down with it out of,
out of the thread basically.
Like you'd be right at the
bottom of my minus 900 downloads,
which is like crazy.
Um,
but it just sad because you can't
have an honest conversation.
You can have a genuine conversation
with anybody from the left right now.
Very few people.
So I just got to say,
it makes me think about the essay or the,
uh,
what you had wrote in red earlier about,
how do you talk to people who are so
ingrained in their own biases or like he
said,
you know,
their own orthodoxy,
uh,
if I'm using that.
Right?
Yeah,
that's fine.
Yeah.
How do you,
how do you get through to people?
Like how do you get through people
that are at Peterson says they're
ideologically possessed,
which I think is a really good way to
put it because that's really what it is.
I remember kind of being,
I'd never really don't think I was
ever really ideologically possessed,
but I remember definitely pushing the
left sort of leftist agenda because I
really thought it was like,
you know,
I thought it was a good thing.
You know,
you're helping people by taking rich
bastards money and given it to the four
people,
right?
Like Robin Hood,
Robin Hood is always seen as a good guy.
Uh,
but I really thought about it for awhile.
I'm like,
well,
what really matters is that we make life
as good as possible for the most amount
of people possible and the system
that's done that is capitalism.
And if we are going to suck it up that
there's some rich guys and there's some
poor guy's,
then it's all going to
be better in the end.
But there's just this resentment
people have just to have it now.
You know,
they,
they would kind of cut off
their nose to spite your face.
Hmm.
So getting back to China real quick,
uh,
we're exactly where we,
you were talking about
highlands book in the uh.
Oh yeah.
So yeah,
so there's like a battle ideological
battle between like authoritarian
collectivism and uh,
I guess the starship troopers
version of liberalism as Sargon this,
I'm a
show,
or what do you call it?
It's this little video he wrote,
he did about starship troopers.
It's like the Jordan Peterson a utopia.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mentioned,
uh,
this is really a,
a Peterson Ism.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and the,
the counter so happens the,
the feet China,
right?
So the human collective wisdom is gone,
but then when they come across the,
enact a Arachnids they are collectivists
like the way they think is the,
there's no difference in the
individual and the whole.
So they don't care if
they lose the individuals.
Nobody be like,
as a whole still exists.
Um,
but humans aren't like that at all,
like they're way more individual.
So when bugs destroy the
entire planet of humans,
just like whatever,
it's like killing one bug them and
they don't care about the one bug.
So why would they care about killing 8
million individuals or however millions
of individuals because they just think
about themselves as the collective,
as long as,
as long as the collective survives,
they don't care.
Um,
so there's like that contrast between,
um,
so that's the weird thing with
the Russos and Marxist and
communist ideals of the collective will,
um,
Russo goes into this idea that if you're
a person that kills another person,
if you kill an individualist and
collectivist because you're working,
uh,
in favor of the collective goal
or collective will he called it,
um,
it doesn't matter that you killed the
person because the individual doesn't
matter.
And I just think that's kind
of disturbing because I mean,
if you apply,
it sounds all good in theory,
but if you apply that in real life,
like you could kill anybody,
you know,
that you could justify it for that reason.
And I think most people,
if they,
I think most people look at the,
sort of like the fluffy parts
of communism and they think,
okay,
it's not
so bad,
but when you really dig
down to what it leads to,
um,
if people are actually
bothered to look at it,
which I don't think most do,
um,
they would see that.
It's like disgusting.
No,
it's worse than baby killers.
That's why.
That's why they get the helicopter.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I just saw,
I just read an article on
dredge recently about a,
uh,
serial killings,
a possible serial killing
sell in the states.
Um,
but yeah,
I,
you know,
I don't know,
I had never heard of it,
but,
you know,
they were this group basically
where they were finding these,
uh,
what they thought were suicide
or possibly suicides are they,
you know,
they have found all this,
uh,
the smiley face artwork and they're
thinking it might be a cell of serial
killers,
um,
you know,
rather than just
individuals that you know,
are linked that use the dark web.
And I thought that dark.
I thought that the dark web was largely
already infiltrated by the federal
government and it was near impossible
to stay anonymous at this point.
Um,
if not impossible because of the way
things are stamped through the internet
protocol system.
Um,
I thought that was gone.
I mean,
I thought the federal government
and had a complete hold,
so it makes me wonder about this story,
but,
and so the people that are being targeted
supposedly are the best of the best
college kids.
Like,
uh,
very bright,
you know,
very athletic,
very good looking kids.
All these kids were found to have Ghb,
which is the date rape
drug in their system.
And yeah,
so it's a.
So basically,
you know,
um,
people take Ghb to uh,
I don't know how familiar
you are with drugs.
Individuals take dhb.
It's just a,
you know,
it's like a,
like it makes me feel good.
It makes you feel good.
I mean it's not just a date rape drug.
There's individuals that take it to
um,
so it was a guy in high school,
I took it,
he took it so much,
the old and we were,
it was kind of just kind of a funny guy,
but we've got all set
your date rapes himself.
Was this kind of
like,
it was such a loser here that day.
Pray for himself.
But
anyways.
But yeah,
so,
you know,
it's just a weird thing and I'm,
it makes me think that,
you know,
who could be doing it,
you know people who are collectivists,
you know,
they don't like the individual.
I don't like the,
if it's even real,
you know,
who knows if I think,
well,
I think they're probably just like,
they're probably like no
pathological individuals,
uh,
you know,
so I think we should just shoot
this pupil up to be honest.
Um,
and it reminds me of the,
uh,
I can't remember Peterson said this,
but it was between the wild
hundreds and the 16 hundreds.
The,
I think the violent death rate in
Europe went down by like an order of
magnitude.
So I think it was like $1,000.
There was no one for 10,000
and that's because they,
the law and order started coming into
effect and he basically started killing
all the criminals off.
Um,
so,
but I mean,
I think that when in our society,
the crime like that is so rare.
It might just be that this
person's just a genetic,
you know,
you can't really eliminate it because
it just pops up once in a while.
Sort of like a rare disease.
So.
Well,
it's hundreds of murders now.
Yeah.
Hundreds of hundreds of
suspected murders in all,
in different cities in the United States.
All bearing the same,
not all,
many bearing the same.
A toxicology reports,
uh,
finding the,
if I can remember correctly,
finding the graffiti,
the similar graffiti in the same areas.
Uh,
and they think that it,
like I said,
it's a cell,
it's a group of individuals
that can change,
like there might be so many individuals
that they can just basically like
interchange themselves in him,
you know,
at any given will.
And that's the thing.
It's like,
it just,
it's really fucking suspect.
Do you know what I just heard about it.
I mean,
I just read it on.
I forget that,
you know,
I should try and pull it up.
I don't know that,
you know,
drugs,
just an aggregate of news sources.
I always hate dimension drudge,
but I almost never remember the actual
which matters where I'm getting the,
who's putting out the story.
Um,
I haven't seen it yet,
but I,
I,
I go by this mantra that
the truth is the truth,
no matter what the source.
So if it's true,
then I don't care about the source.
Yeah,
I mean that's the thing.
How do you find out if it's true or not?
Right?
Yeah.
I mean,
I never even heard about it.
I don't ever hear about it in the
mainstream media or anything like that.
This,
I mean a group of serial
killers rather than,
uh,
well,
the,
the thing with the conspiracies as
the more people that are involved,
some moral likely or the less likely
it's going to remain a conspiracy is the
more mouths and more
ears than more mistakes.
So if it is,
a lot of it is a lot of people
hopefully will be found out.
Yeah,
fucked up.
I'm trying to find just to post it.
Oh yeah.
Hey Joshua.
I've read 19,
84,
three times.
Um,
it's,
it's a good [inaudible] do you know,
it's funny as I.
every time I read it again,
it got better.
Like I got more from it.
Um,
yeah,
yeah.
The Brotherhood school.
Yeah.
That in brave new world.
It was funny.
My,
the AP English 12 teacher,
he's like,
uh,
so I got to,
you guys got to read this.
He's like,
I don't know why they want you to read 19,
84 was like,
I don't know where the world's going,
but it's required reading
now that brave new world.
He's like,
so not going to be,
not going to get around to
some of the other books.
I like the teacher,
but nothing.
It was just kind of interesting.
He was making sense.
I came across this a thing of the day
on reddit and it was someone that was
like,
it was like a probable,
not see a guy like a
neofascist or whatever.
And there's a reddit called 1984 and
the guy made a post like detailing about
how 1984,
it's actually left pick a
leftist collectivism rather
than write collectivism.
Which is actually,
I think that's true.
Um,
and uh,
I got down voted for agreeing with a
Nazi about something that was true.
I thought,
I agree,
but just be agreeing that
what he said was true.
Doesn't mean I agree with Nazi-ism,
which just disagreed with the,
you know,
his assessment.
Yeah.
I was trying to,
like,
they like,
and the guys were like looking
through his post history,
I think his name was,
um,
something white,
something four slash four slash
2014 year years or something.
So I was just like,
well,
obviously he's a Nazi but I don't
care because that's not what,
that's not what the argument is.
That's not what he's saying.
The argument is that it's
a leftist collectivism.
And I was like,
oh,
that's true.
But a lot of people are like,
get out of here.
You're not see like,
I don't want to hear your opinion.
And you know,
I just thought that was
stupid because like,
it doesn't matter.
You know,
Santa Claus said it
doesn't make a difference.
Right?
Yeah.
I just think it's a bad rhetoric
on the front of the left.
They,
you the MPC meme.
Yeah.
It's like that whole thing,
you know,
they've got a limited set of responses
and the run through them and then after a
while they just,
you're just like,
what the fuck do I even
say to you anymore?
You,
are you even a human being,
do you think?
Yeah.
Um,
I've,
I,
I've had a lot of,
I actually quit facebook,
I got rid of my facebook because I was
having these conversations with people
that were just completely retarded.
Like you,
you talked to people
they don't like consider
consider what you have to say.
No,
they just,
they have their,
they have their spiel.
Orange Man,
dad,
yeah,
I have facebook,
but I never interact,
never post anything.
I mean it's,
yeah,
well I have this,
uh,
I have a fake facebook account
that I use once in a while.
Um,
it's called,
uh,
I joined this group called
left versus right or whatever,
and it says I can pull a group.
Um,
but at the beginning it was like shit
posting and then it became political than
it was more shit posting.
But now it's a very often.
But I think the trumps is basically
divided between trump and anti trump now,
which is kind of lame.
But I did.
Anti-Trump guys are guys I used to
argue with a lot because I used to be a
socialist.
Right.
So I've,
I've been the things I've,
I've changed and adapted and I've learned,
I'm different,
not really learn different ideas,
I've absorbed different ideas and now
I just think completely differently,
you know,
so,
but it took me,
it took me listening to people with
different views and taking their thoughts
genuinely rather than just,
uh,
you know,
ignoring them because they
think differently than me.
And you know,
orange man.
Good.
Yeah.
I don't,
I don't know what,
you know,
for people who
don't necessarily like a.
So I listened to a Jimmy Dore quite a bit,
you know,
I like June cleaver.
He's good.
But you know,
he had,
you know,
he,
he's a,
he's a comedian so,
you know,
and he,
maybe it might've been a
talk show host or talent.
I mean he,
uh,
he talks sometimes like he's a,
like he's a baseball announcer or a news
announcer for the Midwest.
Jimmy Dore,
the Jamie door from the young Turks,
right?
Yeah,
I didn't know him when he
was at the young Turks.
I just a found him
piper.
Oh,
do they?
Cause he,
uh,
he was like yelling at Alex Jones and
you're like it on the and so the column,
the spitting viper a that
was door that spit on him.
Yeah.
I don't think he meant to.
I think it was just like he
was just excited or something.
Yeah.
Maybe it's just Chicago.
He's a,
I mean it's like,
you know,
people from Chicago,
people from New York,
hockey fans,
you know,
they all kind of similar,
it's like you don't
take shit from anybody.
You know,
I heard Jimmy Dore just like fucking
ripping into somebody and uh,
I mean one time I heard him
kind of go off on somebody.
I'm like,
man,
I feel like I know that guy is.
And then he's like,
oh,
I,
you know,
he was,
he lived in the Chicago land area.
And I'm like,
oh,
that's why.
Because I,
you know,
I,
it,
it's kind of a cliche thing,
but you know,
when you grow up in Chicago land area,
you run into certain people who have
the same attitudes and you know,
it just,
he's actually like a
relatively reasonable,
like leftist.
Like he,
I don't think he's as great.
I think the pro like crazy,
funnily enough,
I think he's more reasonable than
like [inaudible] and like an,
I guess
just casper the friendly ghost.
I've got a in,
which is weird because
he's kind of the crazy one,
but I think it's just probably where
he's from as he said northeastern over
Chicago,
Midwest yet.
But uh,
oh,
maybe he went a.
all right,
get you to fair.
Come on,
get down.
He,
uh,
he was talking to,
they had done a funny thing again,
let's back up.
And they were talking about immigration
and trump made the remark and I don't
know why he made the remark.
I mean,
I guess he just does it because he's
just going to talk and say whatever he
wants,
which is fine.
Uh,
but he was like,
the uh,
immigrants have the best cars
and he didn't say Emirates,
sorry.
He's like,
the kind of,
it seemed to be taken out of context
and it was like they've got the best
vehicles and then Jimmy Dore and
then his wife and Ron Falconi,
they kind of going off and they're like,
what do you mean,
think of the best cars,
you know?
And it's like,
like I didn't see anything before it and
I don't catch the live shows because he
only cuts,
clips of his shows and then you,
you don't get to see the full live
show unless you're a supporter,
a Patriot supporter or
wherever that works.
Yeah.
I don't support them because I don't,
it's not in because I like them comes
because they don't have enough money now.
But uh,
because I liked their content,
but I mean he was totally,
they're totally taken
trump out of context.
But then I just stepped back for a second.
I'm like,
he's a fucking comedian.
I mean,
it's not,
but you know,
I guess it depends.
You know,
it,
you know,
you,
you really shouldn't get a free pass.
You know,
no matter who you are,
if you're trying to influence
the political process.
I guess that's,
it comes down to like
a duty responsibility,
you know,
who am I affecting a WHO's going
to believe the shit that I say?
Anyway,
so I mentioned this because I made
a comment in the section like,
I believe it was the
coyotes and of course I got
probably 20 comments down and people just,
you know,
you,
I guess you believe what you believe.
A lot of bullshit,
I'm sure.
And just all this shit and
they're thinking about it.
I'm like,
man,
these people do not like trump and
they definitely don't like to be a
put on the spot,
I guess.
I Dunno.
Yeah,
yeah,
that's true.
If they don't like,
um,
they don't like conflict
with their ideology,
that's for sure.
Yeah.
If,
uh,
a son that's seems to be common
amongst most of the leftist ideologue.
Yeah.
But yeah,
so I don't know,
I'm,
I'm starting to get like the.
Sorry,
go ahead.
Uh,
the young,
the young Turks,
I find them to be pretty,
pretty crazy.
Like I used to actually
be a subscriber to them.
They,
I thought they were kind of
reasonable back in the day,
but now,
but now that they've kind of gone,
I guess for the last couple of years I
eventually decided subscribed like this
whole sites,
like this little group is bullshit.
Like they,
they just make shit up half the time.
Are they there are so slanted,
you know,
like it's hard to explain that.
I don't know,
I just,
I'm totally lost.
I lost faith in them,
so I just unsubscribed and
they've gotten worse since.
So I guess it was a good idea.
Yeah.
Uh,
I've never really watched
the young Turks infective,
watched them more just to hear them,
what they're saying
a w
recently.
But I mean,
I don't,
I never think would go like,
yeah,
like just Kinda,
you know,
I kinda want to observe,
what they're talking about,
the stories that they're talking about,
how they're framing it,
how the framing certain stories.
Uh,
it's just really interesting to me.
no.
Well,
who else do you,
uh,
do you ever listen to v?
No,
that's.
Yeah,
see,
I know there's a lot of
good youtube youtubers.
A,
I don't know how old
the has been on Youtube,
but I've always kind of associated
Sargon the thunder foot probably from,
from like 2013 from
when I first heard her.
I don't know if these have
been around since then,
but I don't know that many that
I would find more interesting,
you know?
Uh,
there's a couple,
there's a couple I've
been listening to lately.
Um,
count Denckla.
Uh,
it was one,
um,
Sargon was,
I think it started with Sargon and then
from there I got to dangle a because of
the Nazi punk thing and then I think I
then eventually it was like I would hear
v quite a bit of a star events.
I was like,
oh,
check out with V and e.
he's actually pretty interesting.
He has like a,
I like b because he's a little bit unique.
Like he has different
views from eastern Europe.
It was like a completely different view.
Um,
so he kind of gives me some
good arguments and points.
I mean,
I don't,
I try to take anybody as orthodoxy,
but I find that he's open enough and
he's also a lawyer and a doctor too,
like he's trained to be both,
so he's pretty smart.
Um,
so I like to Dab a devil in his,
his work and same with
Sargon and a contact lead.
Then there's this guy just
started listening to a shirt,
shirt,
fat attackers,
a Canadian guy.
Um,
he mostly does gaming,
but he does like a at d and
d stream with a v and Sargon.
So I listened to that too because
now he usually has stuff inside this.
Interesting.
But,
um,
yeah,
so those are,
some of the guys listen to
also listen to Owen Benjamin,
who's kind of been a weird lately.
Um,
I found him,
I love his comedy.
I think he's fucking hilarious,
but he's got a little bit weird with the,
the uh,
what is it
about the moon landing stuff?
And now he's onto him.
I think he's six months from flat earth,
but who knows?
Oh,
it's just my,
my guest.
I could be wrong.
Uh,
you also could just be fucking with
everybody because that's the way it is.
Yeah,
I've thought that for a little while.
I don't know.
I mean,
we never know really exactly
what anybody's doing a.
I mean,
you got youtube and you know,
don't ever know what direction
they're moving in and a,
he could be totally different person and
no in real life.
Uh,
well not what I mean
when you're not around a
camera and an audience.
I don't know.
I Dunno,
I've listened to it.
I've listened to probably a few hours
worth of his last few streams and uh,
I've always thought like,
you know,
I don't necessarily think
the moon landing was faked,
but even if it was,
you know,
if it was,
it wasn't,
it wouldn't give me any more faith
in,
excuse me,
in the intelligence agencies or the
federal government telling you the truth.
I mean already,
you know,
the,
the state is there to,
you know,
in its capacity now is there to deceive.
I mean,
doesn't want people to
know the state of war.
The state of,
you know,
made that mistake in Vietnam.
I mean,
uh,
showing the effects of a war on TV,
you know,
won't happen now,
but you never hear anything.
So,
I mean,
not that
that's what he's constantly railing about.
Oh,
you know,
the federal government or the intelligence
agencies are lying to people in the
military.
Industrial Complex is lying.
That's not what he's going.
He's going on specifically
about the moon landing,
being fake,
but,
you know,
I don't really care how.
Yeah,
I don't really care you.
I don't really care either.
A,
if you've ever seen
the movie interstellar.
Yeah.
Was it the
Mcconnell here?
River?
Yeah.
Okay.
They,
uh,
they say in school there that the moon
landing was faked just so that they could
defeat the Russians would expend so
many resources that it would cause the
article apps to try to catch up.
Yeah.
Uh Huh.
But,
uh,
I mean,
I think that's probably bullshit,
but I,
I think,
uh,
I think there's enough evidence
that we went to the moon to make it.
I mean,
I'm,
I'm willing to entertain the idea that
it didn't happen just because I'm open
minded,
but um,
I'm not convinced that it didn't happen,
so yeah,
I'm pretty convinced to happens.
But if something popped up and it was,
I thought it was reasonable
evidence and I've considered it.
No,
no,
I'm not close minded.
Yeah.
Ultimately I think that's all fine.
I think it's pointless though.
Gutierrez.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah,
I think there's enough.
You went blank there,
you know,
Benjamin brings up the.
Oh,
all the telemetry data is
in
erased,
deleted.
The tapes have been written over.
It's like,
well,
I don't necessarily think that's true.
I mean I've definitely
found that it is true.
It's like it could just
be like a stupid accident.
Like I wouldn't put up to malice what
can be excused this stupid or it's just
hired the intern.
The intern works for free,
doesn't know what the fuck he's doing.
Someone tells them to go do something.
He does it and it's like,
wait,
what did you do?
Oh,
fuck,
you know,
is the moon
or a portion of it.
Yeah.
Or a portion of it and it's like,
well,
let's just say it's all gone now.
That,
that wasn't my 19,
96 Christmas recording on
the vcr of home alone too.
It was,
it was the fucking moon landing.
No.
Yeah,
yeah.
And that's the thing is that the right
hand never knows what the left hand's
doing it in,
you know,
when it comes to the federal government.
So it's like,
it's like don't think for
a second that you can put,
you know,
government and competency in the same,
uh,
in the same sentence.
You know what I mean?
It,
it's,
it's like
I,
I work for the government and we
order like gloves that are there.
They are come with a number,
right.
So you write down the number,
you say,
I need this club from this company,
this number because it
meets all the standards.
Right.
And then they bring in these
clubs and the guidance.
You just looked at a picture or something.
Then you've got the goals that weren't
met or didn't meet the standard.
So I got my work,
puts his hands in chromic acid,
it leaks through and gets all over his
skin and burns the shit out of his hand
and it's because of the day went and
bought the glove that looked like it,
but it's not the,
it's not the specific number,
but we told them which one to get,
but they go ahead and pass down through
like four more people before it.
Finally,
the guy that actually orders it,
then he doesn't eat so disconnected from
the bottom of the pyramid there that he
doesn't know the difference.
So we end up getting fucked over a lot.
That's the procurement of basic supplies
with the government is ridiculously
convoluted.
Like it shouldn't be,
but it is.
It's funny because I was thinking,
uh,
you know,
it's still in the back of my mind going
into the air force into a contracting,
which is basically the guy who.
I mean,
that's what I would want to do because
it has the best when you get out of the
military as one of the best.
Yeah.
Returns I guess in the civilian world.
I mean,
you,
you can walk out of the military
Friday and on Monday walk in as a,
basically you have a job almost
immediately in contracting,
but yeah,
it was one of the same thing.
But um,
yeah,
so that sucks that because you know,
there's,
it has to go through so many people that,
you know,
people end up getting hurt over it.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's,
but you know.
Yeah.
What,
how,
how are you,
how are your drinking laws in Florida?
Like do you like to walk around with
a beer in hand or how's that work?
Uh,
I don't know if you got to grab a beer
and walk down the street and a cop sees
you,
they're not going to care.
They're going to care.
Yeah.
I think you're going to care.
Um,
and there are actually some dry.
There are some dry counties,
I think there in Alabama,
not too far from it
here.
It means he can't even
have a beer at home.
Yeah,
it means you can't buy alcohol.
Uh Oh,
at all.
Uh,
I believe,
um,
when I looked at it,
it might just be on the weekends,
but I,
for some reason I remember that actually.
I mean it may be that there's
dry counties for some reason.
I'm remembering having the conversations
with some coworkers because,
you know,
I'm kind of new here.
I mean the part of the reason that I've
not necessarily just doing the youtube
thing but kind of on here is I haven't
really made that many friends here,
you know,
I don't really go out and do that much.
So that's tough when
he moved to a new area.
Yeah,
I'm on the Internet a
whole lot more and uh,
you know,
so they're telling me about some
of these areas and yet I don't,
I think in this town,
crestview,
and I think maybe in,
I don't know if it's all Florida,
that probably just the county
that you can't buy alcohol
past a certain time and you
can't buy alcohol on Sundays.
I don't know.
Yeah,
I don't care.
I don't drink that much anyway.
You know,
like every once in awhile
when I was in Chicago,
you know,
we'd to nice restaurants and they'd serve,
nice craft beer and you drink a pint of
something that's $20 and you think it's
overpriced and then you
taste it and it's like,
oh my God,
turn hardly tastes like beer.
And it's like the $20 was worth it
and you never tasted that again.
You know,
you definitely not going to
get any domestic shit that.
Well,
I don't really integrate too much.
Yeah,
I don't.
I usually just have a beer.
It's like after the hockey game,
here's a beer after a game,
like it's like drinking gold to say,
I kind of described under the word.
I remember the first time
I played a soccer game,
they had a beer after,
it was like Canadian Molson Canadian.
It's absolute garbage.
And it tasted like heaven.
Like I was,
I was drinking like the series of angels,
you know,
and it was so fucking refreshing.
Um,
and then so now I appear
after every hockey game.
It makes it,
makes the game even if you
lose or you lose or win,
it's,
it's still good.
Yeah.
Beard does taste like socks wet sometimes,
but if you have some,
if you have good beer that's not so bad.
Yeah.
Light Beers,
you know,
domestic beers tastes like sex wet.
But I mean you start getting
into the high end craft beer and
uh,
like you get three floyds which is a
company out of Indiana and I think they
have a festival once a year and they
serve a beer at that festival and you have
to buy tickets to.
You have to buy a Stein and tickets just
to drink the beer and it's dark horse
or something like that or dark Lord.
Um,
but then three floyds makes
other like they make a pint,
I forget what it was,
but my buddy,
we were leaving Koumas which
is this metal bar they have.
It's a gourmet food,
like really high end food
burgers really high in Burgers.
Um,
and they're named after metal
bands like led Zeppelin,
Judas priest,
a ghost,
you know?
Yeah.
Anyway,
so,
and then they also serve,
they've got a whiskey bar and then
they also have a beer selection and as
leaving,
what time?
Everybody's like,
man,
you,
you want to try a $20 beer?
I'm like,
what,
what are you talking about?
20 bucks man,
what the fuck?
And I,
and this is just before,
like a group of us were leaving.
I'm drinking it and I'm like,
oh my God,
this is so good.
And I,
I,
I can find out what that was.
But I mean,
once you have a real decent flavor,
a decent beer,
it's like,
yeah,
it's,
it's worth it.
But
that's,
it's a,
we have this,
we have this kind of cheap used to be
really cheap brand called Lucky Logger
[inaudible],
uh,
which we still have,
but it's just now it's more like a,
it's been,
it got so popular that it kind of
moved into the medium price bracket.
So,
but that's what we have at our
games basically every time.
I mean if I was at a party
or is I post playing a sport,
yeah,
I would have no problem drinking whatever,
you know,
for the longest time we drank keystones,
30 racks keystones,
you know,
I mean is what you do at colleges,
you go to a big college parties
and do the cheapest shit you can.
Yeah.
Kegs full of the cheapest shit possible.
Keystone now I used to,
uh,
but I'm,
I'm two years older than my brother,
so when I turned 19 I forget for him
for high school and I'd get like the
cheapest,
the cheapest beer with the highest
alcohol content and it's called the lucky
force eight.
It was like the,
it was so disgusting like the.
But he'd bring them to school to the
parties and he'd sell them two for five
bucks,
which is like if he sold I think 18 of
them and the 24 you could get six if you
had six TV smashed and uh,
and you could sell the rest and make
you pay for all the theory part.
Have two for five bucks though.
Is highway a fucking
robbery for those beers?
But I mean the kids,
they can't get the beer.
So it's like you.
Yeah.
And uh,
yeah,
it was kind of funny
but I remember whenever,
I think I tried one once and it was like,
like regular lucky,
you know,
it's definitely,
it tastes like beer,
but like lucky for say like
it tastes like horse piss.
Was it like,
was it a uh,
I know we had,
I don't know about what
you're talking about,
but then we had like
steel reserve which was a
uh,
steel reserve was um,
was the percentage of,
I dunno,
but it super cheap.
I don't know that it was that much higher.
Oh yeah.
Well I think there's more liquor.
We have that too.
They always get sold out because I'm
really close to a native reserve,
but the,
so the malt liquor,
but then there's like the highest beer
was the highest grade that was like mass
produces eight percent here.
Um,
you can get like higher
but they're more expensive.
Um,
but just for like the
shit beer eight percent.
And it was like,
the reserve is like between,
I'm looking at Google page six and eight,
and it,
man,
I had it,
I tried it,
we went down to Carbondale,
which is a huge party college.
And
uh,
Elena and
it is terrible.
It was awful.
And there's nothing else.
It's whatever.
So
I,
you've got to do
a 1000 miles in Russia when I was like 17,
there was like,
if you're thinking you had to be 13 to
have fear or something like that when in
the restroom.
So I was like 17.
So it was totally,
I was like getting an hour and a,
it's a in this under or in Moscow
and it's like this underground pub,
just like you have to go down into the
basement or whatever and it's in there.
And everyone's smoking,
like assuming I don't smoke,
but everyone was smoking like a chimney.
So the entire place is just absolutely
filled with smoke from one end to the
other.
You couldn't,
like,
there's a big long table.
They were all sitting at
the public 20 of us and uh,
you couldn't see the other end of it.
And everyone's like,
smoking like crazy.
Oh.
And I went to the Moscow,
Moscow,
a circus and the same.
Same thing.
You can't smoke inside the building.
You can only smoke inside.
The people would ever want
to go to the bathrooms.
And uh,
you,
you know,
how like you go to the bathroom and it's
like a physical last story you can see
through it.
But this was a glass door,
but you couldn't see through it.
It looked like frosted glass
because everyone would go
in there and smoked their
brains out.
So,
uh,
and there's no events.
So you go,
I had to take a piss.
So I like fucking held my breath ran in
and I went in like showered and cleaned
and I came out just like Rican,
like cigarettes.
And I couldn't hold my
breath the whole time.
I had to,
I had to take one breath walls in there.
Oh God.
It was like roads,
like sucking,
sucking on a chimney.
That was pretty funny.
Yeah.
It's one thing I kind of don't mind.
I mean,
in the Chicago land area,
you know,
you can't smoke.
I mean,
it's gotten worse and worse
and for people who smoked,
they ate it,
but it was,
you can't smoke inside of a building,
you can't smoke within
20 feet of the building.
You can't smoke within 50 or
100 because buildings are like,
well,
not,
you just can't smoke in Chicago because
buildings are only 50 feet from you.
Same here.
You can't smoke within
10 feet of a 30 feet.
Now have like a door or
an entrance or a window.
Yeah.
So that basically you have to stand on
the yellow line in the middle of the road
if you want to smoke.
Oh,
I mean,
I'm not,
I shouldn't be against it.
You principle of freedom,
but I hate smoking.
Oh yeah.
It's just like a weird.
I don't care,
but like tobacco and it
seems pointless to me.
It's just like,
it smells bad,
makes you smell bad.
Um,
it gives you cancer.
I've had family members die
of cancer and just like a,
it's.
And they all smoke.
They usually,
they smoke the most of their lives.
It's just watching that.
It's just brutal.
So I don't know.
It'd be one thing if people grew tobacco
theirself and then dried it and rolled
it,
but who does that?
Nobody knows.
Illegal for too much.
A pain in the ass to Bravo.
Yeah.
It'd probably be a whole
lot more healthy for you,
but you did it that way.
I mean,
combusting,
any plant matter,
you know,
cannabis or tobacco is bad,
uh,
we'll combine that physical
process of burning.
Is
it,
you know,
there's carcinogens in cannabis
and this carcinogens in,
uh,
well,
anything that's been radiated,
it's going to have like,
you know,
Carson agenda basically.
Is it tobacco?
Is it a rick irradiated?
Oh No,
it's not,
it's just that because,
uh,
I guess,
um,
like when you break those
carbon bonds and burning it.
Oh,
you see,
you're explaining to me.
Oh,
would I didn't understand what
happens through the admission process.
Okay.
Yeah.
The carbon bonds break and
I'm at reaction creates like,
it releases carcinogens basically.
But that's how I felt.
That's what I was told anyways.
I don't know if I could,
I could be wrong.
I could be bullshitting.
No,
no,
but I,
I'm not trying to,
like if I,
if I'm,
if I'm lying.
So I guess
that's what I was told.
I could be wrong.
I hate,
I hate cold and things where
I'm not completely sure,
but I know.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean if I didn't do that I
probably wouldn't have said it
more than just my own personal
stories during this whole thing.
I mean,
you,
you've contributed probably
90 percent of this,
but uh,
oh,
I'll try,
I'll try my best,
but I don't know.
Yeah,
he's not upset about smoking.
I mean I find it kind of
interesting that Nazi Germany band,
I mean obviously the SS and
yeah,
probably they kinda didn't care.
So in the beginning didn't care
so much about their own smoking,
but
yeah,
I thought it was banned in Germany.
I'm not sure I've been reading
too that I think they did.
I think the worst.
There's videos or movies
that have them smoking,
so maybe they're not accurate,
but I don't know.
I haven't looked into it.
Yeah,
I wouldn't doubt like those
people with those ideas,
but back then they thought
smoking was healthy for,
you know,
I,
I think that,
I think that there were studies done a
clear clinical trials that doctors had
done and they had determined that it was,
uh,
that it was unhealthy and
then it was just band.
Oh,
okay.
Well I know what I mean in the 19 fifties
they would like tell my grandmother
that smoking was good for
the baby because what it was,
was he like,
or no,
not when they're pregnant,
but it was good to smoke when you weren't
pregnant because you'd be breathing in
the smoke and then when you breathe out
it would take their theory was that it
would take all the bad
bugs and stuff with it,
like the viruses and stuff.
But it's total bullshit.
But um,
the,
the idea is kind of funny,
like it would use to recommend
smoking the people for their health.
Yeah.
I guess because maybe because they would
get so sick when they stopped that they
think maybe that was like,
and they were just like
desperately clinging to life
because of the cigarettes.
It's definitely a possibility,
a cursory.
But I'm going to have to get going here
because it's 2:00 now and I'm getting
pretty tired.
Yes.
Twelve o'clock here.
I'm pretty tired too.
So.
Oh,
it was good chocolate talking with you,
man.
You do?
Oh,
I'm down for doing it again if you're,
if you still want to do it again,
so let me know and I'll definitely,
uh,
try and construct more,
um,
for next time.
Um,
so I kinda know,
so.
No,
no,
no worries at.
All I do is just read all the
time and read random random shit.
I try to,
I try to focus more now.
I'm basically because of the
things I've learned from Peterson,
but um,
I,
I just try to read as much as I can.
Um,
no
try to metabolize it I suppose.
But that's the key.
I think just reading,
reading classic literature,
reading,
things that are popular like in,
in the past.
I like op stuff.
I don't really care for her,
but like stuff that's rated as
good by like really smart people.
That's a good way to start.
Yeah.
So that's why I recommend
even even fiction.
This all good
because it gets fixed.
It's fixed.
It's kind of like a time capsule.
Right.
So you learn a little
bit about history too.
Yeah.
If you got anything,
uh,
that.
If you've got anything
you want me to talk to,
to maybe bring up next time,
I'm just to let me know.
I'll,
I'll look up,
I'll try to see what I can learn about
it if I get a chance and then we'll have
to talk about next time
if I,
if I got anything else,
I'll just pass it on to you.
Please do.
Alright.
Alright,
I'll talk to you later.
Alright.
Degrees man.
Have a good weekend.
Okay.
You do see you guys.
Here's my.
Yep.
Thank you.
Right.